oui
bon
super je crois que j'ai oublié toutes mes
fiches bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir à tous ravis de
vous rencontrer effectivement je crois que j'ai
oublié toutes mes fiches dans la loge au bâton
piot on va essayer de je vais essayé d'improviser
comme ça merci d'être avec nous pour ben j'allais
avoir une explication une je vais y arriver une
une phrase un peu triviale si elles sont là en
fait en disant qu'on allait aller au septième ciel
vous allez nous emmener je sais pas j'attends pas
si loin non en tout cas merci d'être avec nous ce
soir pour cette nouvelle conférence dès mardi de
l'exposition c'est merci à vous d'être venus nous
rejoindre ce soir alors vous le savez c'est le 50e
anniversaire du premier pas de l'homme sur la lune
d'ailleurs à ce sujet là je me permets avant même
de vous accueillir vraiment de vous signaler que
notre notre beau planétarium va vous propose déjà
de 2 comment dire de fêter un peu cet anniversaire
et puis et puis que vous préparez des séances
un petit peu particulière pour cet été pour le
prochaine était donc venez bien sûr au planétarium
de l'espace des sciences de rennes il ne faut
absolument pas manquer ce rendez vous il y à il y
en a plusieurs qui vous sont proposés par jour sur
des thèmes un petit peu différent et vous trouvez
tout cela dans notre nouveau programme qui vient
juste de paraître le programme d'avril à juin
comme ça vous aurez un aperçu de tout ce qu on va
vous proposer les semaines à venir alors je salue
bien sûr tout le public présent dans la salle je
salue aussi les internautes qui sont de plus en
plus nombreux à regarder nos conférences les jours
suivant la date de celle ci alors on on peut aussi
découvrir dans le numéro de science ouest du mois
de janvier il avait avait un petit peu anticipé
une interview de vous sur à propos justement des
premiers pas sur la lune ça s'intitule les pieds
sur la lune les yeux vers la terre on y reviendra
tout à l'heure et ce numéro de science ouest du
mois de janvier et bien vous allez le pouvoir le
trouver sur la table du libraire avec d'autres
numéros et comme ça vous pourrez voir aussi
l'interview de philippe besnard eros ben voila je
crois que maintenant on va on va parler de vous on
va on va faire un petit peu plus connaissance vous
êtes journaliste mais journalistes spécialisés
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de cette très belle
revue si elle est est ce parce que certains
d'entre vous doivent connaître dont on dira un mot
tout à l'heure et et puis et ben vous êtes je peux
pas dire tombé dedans quand même quand on parle
si on peut dire ça comme d'audience alors on va le
dire donc alors voilà j'ai lu dans un article d'un
d'un journal d'abord dire que vous êtes originaire
d'une famille d'origine espagnole avec avec ce nom
et dans l'hérault ce que vous avez vécu à limoux
qu il mouille ebooks sais pas comment prononce
limoux limoux petites villes de l'aude pas très
loin carcassonne comme vous pouvez l'entendre
julien et sa occitan et donc j'ai c'est là-bas que
c'est un tout petit je suivais les retransmissions
télévisées des dernières missions apollo donc ses
attentes et moi j'ai une anecdote d'avant cela est
ce que c'est vrai c'est lui c'est écrit dans le
journal c'est par la fenêtre de sa chambre qui
l'a plongé la première fois son nez dans les
étoiles avec une petite lunette astronomique
offert à noël par ses parents enseignants dans la
cité blanquetière à limoux pays occitan et oui ça
c'est vrai mais j'avais 12 ans mais c'était plus
tard [__] ça c'est l'observation astronomique
évidemment oui quand vous disiez tout à l'heure je
suis tombé dedans est un petit c'est la vérité je
suis né en 1939 27 et 27 sept et là j'aimerais
prenez un seul message aurait besoin de moins
mais donc à 69 c'était anticipé un peu le fils
de ma pensée c'était quand même trop petit pour
suivre sa 3h50 du matin devant la télé vous
l'imaginez donc j'ai vu les missions apollo
à la fin d'un synthé aux sons des 12 camps jeu
j'avais un peu le la conscience ce qui se passait
et c'est pratiquement mon plus anciens souvenirs
quand on à 85,1 on a peu de souvenirs de ces âges
là et parmi le peu de souvenirs que j'ai de ces
âges là c'est de regarder la télévision et de
me dire mais quand est ce qu'on va retourner sur
la lune et vous allez voir plus on vieillit plus
on se souvient des souvenirs des premiers premier
premier souvenir devant la télé souvent possible
c'est possible alors votre parcours vous avez fait
sciences po à toulouse vous avez fait une licence
d'administration publique vous mieux cadrer les
choses au kazoo ensuite diplôme de l'institut
français de presse puis un dss techniques
de l'information et de la communication et
alors qu'est ce qui vous a amené comme ça à
vous intéresser enfin vous vous y intéressiez
déjà mais à conjuguer finalement votre passion
et votre travail c'est une rencontre comme bien
souvent la plupart du temps les scientifiques qui
viennent ici nous parle de rencontres qui qui vont
influencer je pense que c'est un petit peu vrai
pour tout le monde mais qui vont influencer leur
parcours vous êtes une rencontre avec alain cirou
qui était rédacteur en chef de ciel et espace
c'est ça en fait j'étais donc passionnés d'espacé
d'astronomie depuis toujours ce qui a influencé
mon parcours et qui a fait que je ne suis pas
devenu ni astronautes naître au physicien c'est
que j'étais nul en maths et donc j'ai fui les
matins ma scolarité j'avais fait un bac littéraire
et quand j'ai commencé à chercher du travail
puisque je voulais être journaliste eh bien j'ai
commencé à envoyer des candidatures comme vous
à l'époque c'était par courrier est l'une des
candidatures c'est peut-être la première lettre
que j'ai envoyée et s'était ainsi les espaces et
c'est une des rares peut-être la seule où on m'a
répondu mais d'accord venu nous voir et donc j'ai
commencé à mettre le pied à l'étrier vraiment
un journalisme acier les espaces j'ai commencé
par ils m'ont confié une rubrique de présentation
des télescopes du marché chaque mois comme j'étais
à la fois astronomes amateurs et journalistes ça
les intéressait j'ai commencé comme ça donc voilà
effectivement cette rencontre s'est faite comme ça
parce que j'avais choisi le journalisme parce que
je ne suis pas devenu castro fils et vous aimez
vous allez succédé à ce poste de rédacteur en chef
alors ça c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup plus tard
j'ai commencé assez d'espacé dans le métier on
appelle ça à la pige donc j'étais pas je ne vais
pas intégré là c'était déjà difficile d'intégrer
des rédactions à l'époque ça l'est encore plus
aujourd'hui j'ai commencé à faire des articles
comme ça qu'ils étaient payés à l'article donc ça
la pige et puis ce n'est qu'en 99 après que j'ai
fait d'autres pige pour d'autres journaux science
et vie notamment qu' on m'a proposé de rentrer à
la rédaction et la gestion d'un trait commun comme
rédacteur et puis après ben vous avait grimpé les
échelons grimper les échelons avec les hasards
qu'on peut rencontrer vous êtes aussi consultant
pour de nombreux médias vous êtes que chroniqueur
dans assez souvent dans l'excellente émission la
tête au carré sur france inter vous avez écrit
plus d'une douzaine d'ouvragés dont histoire des
toiles chez delachaux et nice les observer le
ciel histoire d alors et puis voilà les livres
que l'on peut trouver sur la table du livre vert
qui est venu ce soir de la librairie le fire il
y à celui ci le guide d'astronomie donc mes et
ses deux petits là ce sont des déclinaisons un
petit peu oui en fait on avait publié ce livre qui
est un gros pavé qui se voulait le plus exhaustif
possible pour les astronomes et amateurs il ya
des cartes il ya des tout un tas de conseils
d'observation y compris sur des instruments c'est
un livre qui était cher et puis le l'éditeur a
voulu de décliner à le découper en petits morceaux
un parti alors par exemple voilà quand on observe
les étoiles et les planètes c'est pas la même
technique d'observation que si vous voulez
regarder les nébuleuses et les galaxies se repérer
dans les six à se repérer un logiciel qui sont les
bases pour savoir comment ne pas se perdre parmi
des étoiles et puis il y en ad'autres observer le
soleil la lune qui est encore autre chose que
les planètes et les galaxies alors un mot sur
7 sur cette revue ciel et espace vous pouvez nous
en dire un mot je peux vous en dire plus comment
la soirée d'hier j'ai commencé comme lecteur à 6
l espace à l'époque il y avait des petits concours
j'aimerais jouer j'ai gagné petit concours photos
y avait rien à gagner juste le nom étude publiée
dans la revue non c'est une revue qui existe
depuis après la guerre mais c'était une revue
l'association elle est devenue une revue vendu
en kiosque à la fin des années soixante dix et
elle est devenu mensuel en 82 et bon à l'époque
j'étais un gîte électeurs et naturellement c'est
une revue qui a vraiment l'ambition d'être à la
portée du plus grand nombre on essaie de d'entrer
dans le détail des articles des sujets pardon on
essaie d'expliquer les choses qui sont parfois
complexes on parle de matière noire d'énergie
sombre phénomènes astrophysiques compliqué en
physique solaire tout ce qu'on veut mais on essaie
de le faire sans aucune équation pas une addition
c'est un gros mot pour nous de manière à essayer
de le perdre personnage mais moi le premier je
vous ai dit que j'étais nul amat donc six mois un
premier lecteur du journal en tant que rédacteur
en chef je commence à voir des coiffures arrivé je
vais dire une longue donc c'est une revue certes
qui semble spécialisés comme ça parce que l'objet
de la revue et spécialisés c'est l'astronomie et
l'espace c'est pas très large mais en termes
de d'accessibilité en tout cas moi je fais des
efforts pour qu'elle soit accessible au plus grand
nombre parfois on échoue je le reconnais mais la
perfection et après seulement 2 faut bien faire
avec alors ce soir le thème de cette conférence
est aussi le thème de ce magnifique livre qui
s'intitule ils ont marché sur la lune le récit
ni dix inédits des explorations apollo avec une
préface de bertrand piccard excusez du peu oui
je figure où je les croise et à une émission
de la tête au carré sur un plateau de france
inter on croise beaucoup de monde là c'est très
intéressant si médicaux ont croisé les célébrités
donc c'est toujours très intéressant et bertrand
piccard ça il est connu c'est un explorateur et
il est en plus de cette activité l'explorateur
autre chose qui fait que il me semblait être
la personne appropriée pour préfacer cet ouvrage
c'est que est un petit à l'âge de 11 ans en disant
aux as il vivait avec ses parents en floride
son père et qui était aussi versé par plutôt
vers l'océan que l'océanographie et vivait dans le
quartier où il y avait tous les astronautes et les
astronautes du programme apollo qui était destiné
à aller sur la lune vivaient dans des villas dans
un même quartier y former une espèce de famille
élargie et bertrand piccard qui était gamin aller
avec ses parts à manger chez les armstrong aldrin
et autres autres célébrités aujourd'hui il a vu
ça en tant que témoins privilégiés presque comme
s'il avait été un enfant de ses astronautes là et
le jour du lancement d'apollo 11 il est allé avec
von braun brown il le raconte dans la préface pour
être sûr ne veut pas manquer le décollage donc
j'ai tenté le coup je les ai contactés via son
éditeur et il a il a accepté je ne suis très ravi
alors ce livre là cette passion qui dure depuis
depuis si longtemps et qui débouche sur ce livre
qui que vous avez mis je crois plus de deux ans
et demi un gros pourquoi pourquoi avoir attendu
si longtemps avant de décrire je me le demande
j'étais un peu comme tout le monde je me disais ça
a eu lieu en 1969 moi je connais bien l'histoire
c'est quelque chose je vivais avec j'ai lu pas
mal d'ouvragés dessus et je me disais mais il ya
beaucoup d'ouvragés qui ont été écrits beaucoup
de documentaires et qui ont été faits tout a été
dit qu'est ce que je vais apporter et récemment
thomas pesquet dizaines d'interviews je sais
plus quel média que la première le premier
obstacle qui nous fait obstacle à tous c'est
notre propre auto censure j'ai été victime de
ça comme tous les autres je suis mais qu'est
ce que je vais apporter en fait j'ai pas regardé
j'ai pas regardé au bon endroit j'ai lu tous ses
livres là certains en anglais et et en fait il
y avait un manque les semaines que je n'ai eu
conscience il ya environ trois ans maintenant on
m'a demandé de faire une petite conférence sur
l'une des missions apollo dans un club de région
parisienne je raconte sol dans l'avant-propos et
à la fin de leur conférence je me suis aperçu que
les gens qui étaient assez âgés pour avoir vécu
ces événements finalement ne les connaissez pas ne
savait pas ce qui s'était passé sur la lune tout
le monde bien sûr connaissez armstrong aldrin
le petit pas pour l'homme le bond de géant pour
l'humanité le coup de fil de l'x la rivalité avec
les russes tout ça a été abondamment décrit et et
documentée dans les journaux dans les livres
dans des documentaires mais finalement qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait là haut à partir du moment où
il pose le pied et jusqu'au moment où il remonte
à l'échelle je me suis aperçu que ça n'avait pas
été racontée y compris dans la bibliographie en
anglais il ya un livre qui existe et que j'avais
depuis des années qu'ils racontaient plus ou moins
ça et c'est tout il y avait plein de livres
qui racontait beaucoup d'autres choses les
sélections des astronautes leur personnalité tout
ça a effectivement beaucoup de choses avaient été
dites mais je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
quand même une lacune c'est que la première et
à ce jour la seule exploration d'un autre corps
céleste par des humains n'a jamais été racontée
tout ça existe c'est pas des infos qui sont
cachées ces formes hissés sur des sites ils
sont en anglais c'est un peu des sites de geek
faut aimer ça faut aller chercher l'information
humaine intéressante et quand même enfouis sous
des fatras de choses qui sont très techniques est
plutôt ennuyeuse il faut bien le reconnaître
donc il a fallu que j'aille extraire de cette
vision visionner et coup toutes les images qui
ont été tournées sur les revues on y reviendra
reviendra et oui parce que je suis journaliste il
fallait quand même que j'allais aussi à la source
que j'essaye - même si c'était il ya longtemps
et donc je me suis convaincu petit à petit que
il y avait là quelque chose à faire et je m'en
veux terriblement de mettre auto censuré pendant
autant d'années parce que si je l'avais fait
mettant dix ans plus tôt les acteurs ont été
beaucoup plus nombreux parce que beaucoup
sont morts les astronautes cette époque là
ils ont entre 85 et 90 ans n'a peut-être plus
donc certains seulement évidemment eh ben vous
emmener sur la lune oui tout de suite hein on
redescendra sur terre tout à l'heure quand même
pour vous poser quelques questions parce que
je pense qu'on aura besoin de d'un petit peu
de précisions mais là vous allez nous emmener
rencontrer ses 12 hommes et 12 hommes qui ont
marché sur la lune et séparaient encore incroyable
à l'heure actuelle merci et bonne soirée à tous
ben c'est parti nous allons partir très loin j'ai
commencé mon livre comme je vais commencer cette
conférence par une mission ou pour ceux qui le
savent ça nous a pas échappé n'a pas été envoyé
sur la lune mais autour de la lune je parle de
la mission apollo 8 qui a été lancé en décembre
fin décembre 1968 avec ces trois hommes qui sont
boorman sanders et lovell qui sont choisis par
la nasa pour les premiers à les faire le tour de
la lune pour essayer de devancer les russes vous
savez qu'à l'époque un peu de contexte la russie
et les etats unis se font une concurrence féroce
dans l'espace toutes les grandes deux premiers et
spatiales sont russes premier satellite première
êtres vivants lâcher ne l'est qu'à la fin des
années 50 le premier rhum évidemment dans l'espace
youri gagarine en 1961 et même le premier
sommes vraiment dans l'espace alexei leonov
en 1964 puisqu'il sort de la capsule vostok dans
un scaphandre et reste dix minutes à flotter dans
l'espace comme ça jusque là la russie humaine
et à l'époque la guerre est technologique et à
travers ça idéologique à l'été 1968 les russes
ont déjà envoyé des vaisseau non habité autour
de la lune il clame que ça a marché en réalité ça
marche pas si bien que ça mais les etats-unis se
disent bon lait derrière donc il faut envoyer une
mission autour de la lune on bouleverse l'ordre
d'émission j'y revienne pas là-dessus je vais
pas m'appesantir sur cet aspect là mais tout ça
pour dire qu avec apollo 8 et pour raison de ce
contexte là pour la première fois trois humains
trois hommes vont aller voir ce que d'autres n'ont
jamais vu bien sûr il ya des sondes qui ont déjà
photographié la face cachée de la lune mais ils
vont réaliser eux le voyage de jules verne de la
terre à la lune ils vont être les premiers à nous
raconter et c'est le premier acte d'exploration
humaine de la lune bien qu'il ne soit pas imposée
initialement je voulais faire de ce chapitre en
prologue on l'éditeur a décidé que ça d'être un
chapitre à part entière mais si vous voyez dans
le livre il est beaucoup plus court que les autres
pour moi c'est le prologue c'est l'acte numéro 1
de l'exploration qu'est ce qu'il voit dès qu'il
se satelliser autour de la lune y voit ça il voit
comme me le dira au téléphone j'ai eu la chance
de lui parler bill anders qui est l'un des trois
hommes de la mission apollo 8 ils voient des trous
dans des trous dans un trou et comme il savait que
j'étais français mon accent que vous entendez
là se passe aussi très bien l'anglais vous vous
en doutez il a ajouté c'est comme à verdun donc
un champ de bataille qui nous est familier donc
la première chose qu'on leur demande quand la
capsule apollo a fini de faire le tour de la
lune et ray apparaît puisqu'il ya une coupure des
communications à ce moment là et pas de satellites
pour faire le relais alors dire qu'on leur dit
mais alors c'était comment il disait ça c'était
tout brille c'est des trous dans les trous faut
dire qu'ils sont pas aidés parce que voilà la
vue qu'ils peuvent avoir depuis leur vaisseau mais
il faut savoir que pendant le lancement au moment
où il ya une tour de sauvetage qui s'éjecte les
flammes font fondre du jeune qui se trouve tout
autour des hublots et tout ça vienne maculé les
hublots si bien que les premiers hommes qu'on en
voit autour de la lune ou en très mal la lune il
la voit à travers des blocs sont flous sauf l'un
d'entre eux qui est un peu moins touchées et c'est
pour ça que je vous mets cette photo je sais pas
si ça se voit là sur le grand écran en tout cas si
vous regardez sur les cratères du bas dans l'est
parti à l'ombre on voit comme une brume et en fait
c'est le hublot qui est maculée ça c'est la face
cachée de la lune dont il découvre ça ça c'est une
autre vue la seule chose m'a dit jim lovell qui
faisait partie de la mission qu'ils ont reconnu
c'est ce cratère là vous voyez c'est un cratère à
ces sommes qui s'appelle seul cops qui qui est un
précurseur de la de l'histoire de l'espace et de
la conquête spatiale russe aux alentours de 1900
il a écrit les premiers traités l'astronautique ce
qu'il vient dans l'astronautique donc comme c'est
une sonde russe qui a photographié la face cachée
de la lune et bien les noms sont russes est donc
le seul cratère proéminent que les astronautes
reconnaissent cette seule cause qui met ce cas
paulo 8 et c'est pour ça que c'est aussi une
mission d'exploration au sens profond du terme je
vais y revenir ce cas paulo 8 va surtout découvrir
c'est ça c'est la terre autour de la quatrième en
orbite autour de la lune jusque là les astronautes
avancés avec leurs vaisseaux qui avancent et
reculent au pour des raisons de mise en orbite
et là il oriente le vaisseau vers la lune la
tête en bas et il opère une rotation je vais
vous montrer ça dans un petit ogre ce qui fait
que quand ils réapparaissent pour la quatrième
fois de derrière la lune il voit la terre se
lever alors ce ne veut pas vraiment c'est eux
qui en bougeant font que la terre se lève mais
ils sont totalement surpris bill anders prendre
cette photo ila un objectif assez puissant a enfin
260 mm qui permet de grossir et il demande à jim
lovell de lui passer à une pellicule couleur
et cette photo vous la connaissez tous assez
emblématique c'est peut-être une des premières
photos qui très progressivement parce que je
pense pas qu'à l'époque ça a eu un impact aussi
fort très progressivement a éveillé la conscience
ce que nous sommes finalement un équipage à bord
d'un petit vaisseau spatial perdu au milieu de
l'espace tout noir et c'est d'autant plus marquant
qu'un avant plan vous avez un paysage celui de la
lune qui est qu on me dira plus tard buzz aldrin
d'une magnifique désolation c'est à dire est qu'il
ya pas un arbre un brin d'herbe c'est pas vivable
c'est pas vivable c'est parfaitement au style et à
côté de ça vous avez la terre avec cette couleur
bleue qui est assez chatoyantes alors je vous ai
pas résisté à l'envié de vous montrer comment ça
s'est passé il ya cinq ans à partir des données
de la sonde lunar reconnaissance orbiter les gens
de la nasa est un auteur américain andrew koenig
en russe refabriquer en virtuel cette scène là
on voit la capsule apollo qui alla la tête vers
le bas il y a un appareil photo monté de 20 des
rouleaux qui prendra un automatique ces photos
là l'éclairage a été reconstitué à l'identique
par rapport à cette journée-là qui devait être
le 21 décembre 1958 voyez le cratère et surtout
liverpool chez les seuls qu'on reconnaît et donc
grâce à un modèle 3d de la lune grâce à à tout
informatique on est capable aujourd'hui d'avoir
et la cartographie précise de la lune ils ont
reconstitué ce moment historique de la prise de
cette photo est envoyée là il ya une quelque
chose c'est pas une montagne qui en train de
pousser tout d'un coup c'est la terre qui apparaît
et bill anders est lui chargé de faire les photos
par son hublot y voit çà et là ils s'expriment
tous risques comme au mont dieu quelle photo
là donc il est il est vraiment stupéfait par ça il
prend à rebours manlleu chambre un petit peu parce
que bowman ne voulait pas emporter d'appareils
photo il penser que service qu'est le casser des
instruments de bord à l'intérieur dont il ya
une bataille entre les lignes on prend pas ça
c'est pas sur le sur le programme effectivement le
programme il est là pour photographier la lune pas
autre chose et donc il photographie une première
fois il demanda louvel de lien envoyer à un film
couleur nouvelle et dans la le coffre à bagages
comme celle du module en train de chercher je lui
donne le vaisseau tourne sur lui même et on voit
que la terre à disparaît donc fort qu'il change le
blu voilà le ses légendes et la terre disparaît
de celui de lula et elle va apparaître sur les
deux suivants donc on verse change d'endroit
il a maintenant son film couleur et par celui
de lola ils ont attiré l'une des photos les
thèmes emblématiques et les plus célèbres du
20e siècle et que je vous disais qu'à pour le 8c
l'exploration dans toute sa splendeur c'est ça à
explorer c'est partir pour aller découvrir autre
chose mais c'est aussi revenir et là quelque part
à ce moment là les astronautes reviennent
vers la terre ils ont un regard différent
sur la terre il photographie toute l'humanité
sauf que toi or il ya toute l'humanité sur la
photo sauf 3e qui sont dans la capsule et et
qui permettent d'éveiller cette conscience que
nous sommes finalement tout seul au milieu de
l'espace en train de voler comme ça et que la
terre est un havre de paix mais ça prendra du
temps aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup à l'époque
c'était le début voilà alors on va atterrir sur
la lune ces images là elles sont pas très joli
pour ceux qui sont habitués aux baies les images
de rues mais elles sont historiques ici c'est une
capture d'écran de la caméra de télévision qui a
été monté sur le bord du module lunaire d'apollo
11 qui a été la première mission en juillet 1969
très exactement le 21 juillet 1969 ce module se
pose et neil armstrong le commandant de la mission
des sens les échelons qui convoie pas là mais qui
sont qui sont là il ya neuf barreaux de l'échelle
on y saute sur le patin d'atterrissage une espèce
d'assiette à l'humaniser sous le sous le pied du
module lunaire ils tiennent un bras est encore
accrochée à l'échelle et il pose le pied gauche
sur la lune et déclare c'est un petit pas pour un
homme un bond de géant pour l'humanité alors j'ai
mis comme titre apollo le premier pas bon c'est un
peu bateau mais en fait c'est ça parce que cette
mission elle n'est pas d'exploration c'est à dire
j'ai voulu raconter ce qu'on fait les hommes sur
la lune ils ont fait de l'exploration mais les
premiers armstrong et aldrin sont allés se poser
sur la lune parce que la difficulté c'était déjà
de se poser je ne vous le raconte pas là mais ça a
été quand même assez difficile et armstrong a été
un très bon pilote et ensuite c'était de savoir
si on pouvait sortir sur la lune travailler sur
la lune bref s'en sortir et faire à quelque
chose donc on voit là sur la photo qui est à
côté là c'est une photo qui a été prise depuis la
fenêtre de buzz aldrin par en fait une image d'une
caméra 16 mm hameçon est en train de récolter
un échantillons de roches parce qu'il faut il
faut revenir avec les échantillons si jamais ça
tourne mal avant que le dream descendent donc la
première des choses à faire c'est d'apprendre
à marcher sur la lune à l'époque on ne sait
pas grand chose on sait que le sol de la lune est
assez ferme on sait que là je vais vous mettre en
même temps comment ils apprennent à marcher vous
allez voir que leur programme alors ça fait ils
ont planté le drapeau et eu déjà pas mal de choses
qui sont faites ici armstrong est là en train de
ranger des échantillons et celui qui virevoltent
un peu autour ces buzz aldrin alors l'impression
que c'est un gamin comme ça qu'il a qui s'amusent
comme ça a sauté un peu comme l'est du pont sur
la lune dans tintin est en fait ça fait partie
de son boulot sur son sur sa check list aldrin
il doit apprendre à marcher il doit apprendre à
marcher sur de plusieurs méthodes alors d'abord en
faisant des départs vous allez le voir pendant que
dans que je parle et il doit faire ça évidemment
devant la caméra alors qui a été déplacé alors
par des pros qui a pas de wifi dont il ya un fil
dans lequel le amstrong banques de se prendre
les pieds et donc de couper la retransmission
télévisée à un moment donné on voit aldrin voilà
qui qui avance et regarder sur ses pieds cas ils
envoient de la poussière comme ça ça fait pas un
petit nuage ça fait ça fait comme si c'était fait
chaque poussière avance comme comme une balle de
fusil en quelque sorte un n'est pas il n'y a pas
d'atmosphère donc c'est une trajectoire balistique
ça ça va beaucoup amusé les les astronautes aussi
donc aldrin virevolte mais les consignes de
la nasa voilà ils essayent de changer voir
si c'est difficile de changer de direction il
s'amuse bien et on lui demande vraiment de on
demande aux astronautes à la mesure du possible
de rester toujours dans le champ de la caméra
leurs réserves d'oxygène leur permettre de tenir
quatre heures à 4 heures et demie mais la sortie
sur la lune est limité volontairement à deux
heures pour au cas où il y aurait un problème
pour le retour qu'on ait le temps de le régler
voilà il fait des petits ponts de kangourou c'est
une des méthodes mais c'est comme ça que les
astronautes des missions suivantes appellerons
cette marche c'est la marche par bones kangourou
comme les stéphanois sont quand même assez rigide
faire un pas puis l'autre c'est un peu difficile
donc c'est aussi simple de faire des petits bonds
comme ça et ça marche très bien parce que sur la
lune la gravité est six fois moindre que sur la
terre donc on a beau être équipés de scaphandres
qui pèse à peu près 80 kg sur terre sur la lune ça
peu à peu près 26 kg quelque chose comme ça où
une vingtaine de kilos donc voilà le dream qui
ceux qui se baladent et on demande surtout aux
astronautes de ne pas prendre de risque on doit
aussi déployé quelques expériences scientifiques
quand même c'est un peu dommage d'avoir fait
l'autre le trajet aussi loué 380 mille kilomètres
pour ne pas tenter d'en savoir un peu plus sur la
lune et parmi ces expériences cela ici c'est la
première chose qui est déployée avant même le
drapeau américain que vous voyez au centre c'est
ce que les astronautes appellerons par la suite le
drapeau suisse premier drapeau sur la lune c'est
un drapeau suisse en fait c'est une expérience
on dirait une feuille de papier aluminium assez
grande sûrement une expérience qui consiste à
capter les protons émis par le vent solaire pour
voir comment la lune ne les reçoit et il faut la
déployer au début pour la remballe et rambo les
le petit morceau de papier aluminium à la fin pour
qu'ensuite on aime maximum de données et cette
expérience a été conçu à berne en suisse donc le
des six astronautes ont l'habitude de plaisanter
s'était procuré en disant que le premier drapeau
sur la lune c'est pas dans le premier cas c'est le
drapeau suisse et accessoirement cette photo que
vous voyez là c'est la première photo d'un homme
sur la surface de la lune armstrong a photographié
aldrin talent qui descend le long de l'échelle
jusqu au moment où il est sur le patin mais
techniquement il est pas sur la lune il est encore
à bord du vaisseau spatial la première photo d'un
homme sur la lune c'est celle là évidemment il
y a le symbole avec le drapeau américain lassés
aldrin qui est au garde à vous devant le drapeau
américain que les astronautes auront du mal à
planter parce que c'est du ressort de le sol de
la lune il ya de la poussière au début mais très
rapidement c'est dur il avait peur d'une chose
c'est que le drapeau se casser la figure pendant
la retransmission télévisée ce qui aurait été
assez déplorable pour une si belle victoire et
enfin la dernière image ici on voit leur hymne
qui déploie alors deux instruments on envoie un
légèrement derrière lui c'est un réflecteur laser
qui permet depuis la terre à grâce à un télescope
on envoie des rayons laser ça rebondit on calcule
le temps dans la vitesse de la lumière et on peut
mesurer la distance de la lune au centimètre près
en renouvelant l'expérience fréquemment depuis
cette époque là les astronomes arrive à savoir
comment évolue l'orbité lunaire c'est comme ça
qu'on sait que la lune s'éloigne de quelques
centimètres par an et c est au premier plan
le l'outil avec des panneaux solaires c'est un
sismomètre tout simplement qui grâce à une antenne
va enregistrer les séismes qui sont éventuellement
en cours sur la lune la caméra de télévision et
là bas au fond donc ils sont légèrement en
dehors du champ en fait et ils sont derrière
le module lunaire qui est là et voilà ce que ça
donne il ya une sorte de don josé par utah leur
l'una reconnaissance orbiteur qui est en orbite
autour de la lune depuis les années 2010 et qui
photographient la lune avec une résolution de 30
cm c'est ça veut dire que les plus petits pixels
dans les meilleures conditions font de 30 cm de
large donc on voit beaucoup de détails évidemment
ce sont des atouts cartographier la lune en
entier et dont l'endroit où s'est posée apollo
11 alors les astronautes ont laissé quand même des
choses ça c'est le bar du module lunaire puisque
pour repartir il ça sert de base de lancement à
l'étagé supérieur où se trouvent les astronautes
donc on voit très exactement l'endroit où il s'est
posé puisqu'il reste une partie du vaisseau là la
caméra est ici le réflecteur laser etc et vous
voyez que tout ça là c'est un peu plus sombres
sont les traces des des astronautes et vous voyez
qui sont pas allés bien loin quand on dit qu'ils
ont marché sur la lune ils ont plutôt piétiner sur
la lune ici vous avez l'échelle 50 m et quand je
vous disais que c'était une mission juste pour
voir si c'était possible de faire quelque chose
sur la lune c'est vraiment ça ils ont la consigne
de ne pas s'éloigner du module lunaire sauf là
et là c'est voix amstrong là c'est la fin de la
sortie il est derrière le lem personne ne prête
attention à lui aldrin est ici en stock passé
derrière et il est censé ramasser des échantillons
à ce moment là le houston leur dis vous reste
dix minutes avant de commencer à rentrer dans
le lem ça fait plus de deux heures et qui sont
là on va me sens qui disparaît et sciemment il
sort vraiment du charme et il fait le petit trajet
que je vous ai montré sur l'image de précédentes
il fait environ 60 net donc sa moitié de terrain
de foot un peu plus en fait un peu plus voilà vous
retrouver dans le camp adverse si vous partez
d'une ligne de but vers l'autre ligne de but et
parce qu'ils prennent l'initiative de d'aller voir
ce cratère pour le photographier alors ça donne
ça c'est un petit cratère qu'il a survolée juste
avant de se poser qui l'a évité et il se dit qu'un
cratère comme le lien enseigner à ces cours de
géologie c'est un petit forage naturel qui a été
fait par une météorite et qui permet de mettre à
jour des roches et donc photographié ça sera peut
être très intéressant pour les pour les géologues
et quand il se retourne vers l'endroit d'où ils
viennent ils photographient le site c'est la photo
de droite avec le module lunaire et qui est posé
on voit le drapeau la caméra et le drapeau suisse
là le drapeau et la caméra voilà donc ça ça dure
trois minutes ils leurs biens reviennent un
très très rapidement il fait quelques photos
il prend pas d'échantillons et sur apollo 11 de
l'exploration se limite à ces trois minutes là qui
sont une initiative personnelle de neil amstrong
qui au lieu de ramasser quelques cailloux de plus
a décidé d'aller voir un peu ce qu'il y avait
dans ce cratère ce que les géologues apprécieront
d'ailleurs alors j'ai passé rapidement sera
paulozz parce qu'il ya pas beaucoup d'exploration
là maintenant on sait où c'est qu'on peut marcher
sur la lune on sait qu'on peut y aller on a
confiance dans le matériel surtout à l'époque il
faut savoir qu'au moment où le module lunaire se
pose et sa fiabilité est encore un jeu c'est quand
même un ange et un risque et on ne sait pas s'il
va être capable de se poser si vous êtes capable
de remonter donc avec apollo 11 on a débroussaillé
tout ça apollo 12 à une mission est une mission
qui survient quelques mois après c'est en novembre
1969 on ne s'est pas souvent d'ailleurs je ne sais
pas si parmi vous il y en a qui connaissent les
noms des astronautes qui était sera mis sur apollo
12 c'est bien c'est bien il ya une personne bravo
c'est normal dans le deuxième en main que vous
voyez là qui est photographié comme ça par la
trappe de sortie parce qu'il fallait se mettre à
reculons descendre comme ça à plat ventre c'est
épique conrad qui est pris par alan bean en
photo une très belle photo au moment où il
descend sur la lune alors la mission d'apollo
12 elle est aussi et surtout de se poser avec
précision parce que il ya un petit couac dans la
mission apollo 11 qui a très bien fonctionné c'est
que armstrong et aldrin se sont posés à plus de
quatre kilomètres de l'endroit prévu en dehors de
l'ellipse qui était prévu si bien qu'on ne savait
pas pendant des mois aux pendant des semaines plus
tôt après la la fin de la mission où s'était posé
ce module lunaire michael collins qui était le
troisième homme en orbite autour avait un petit
télescope il était censé les voir mais il ne les
a pas vus parce qu'ils aient cherché un endroit où
il était censé être il n'y étais pas donc une les
a il n'a pas pu dire où il était précisément et ça
ça pose un problème si on veut explorer la lune si
on n'est pas capable se pose est précisément si
vous définissez des objectifs scientifiques par
exemple un cratère une crevasse ou une montagne
à aller voir et que tout ça doit être apportée de
deux randonnées pédestres ou plus tard de voiture
eh bien il faut il faut absolument se poser au bon
endroit si vous posez en dehors des clous c'est
pas possible vous ne pourrez jamais exploré donc
apollo 12 avaient pour mission de se poser à un
endroit précis et quoi de mieux qu'un endroit
qu'on connaît déjà dans l'océan des tempêtes qui
est une des mers lunaires il ya en 1967 une sonde
spatiale surveilleur 3 s'était posée avait pris
des photos et donc on décide de se poser à côté
de cette sonde on en repère alors ça marche très
bien depuis deux chorales est un très bon pilote
les logiciels de l'époque les programmes pour
se poser au bon endroit en tenant compte des
difficultés qui peut y avoir autour de la lune je
vous passe les détails mais il ya des histoires de
gravitation qui bouge et c'est ça qui est un peu
fait dévier apollo 11 donc on remet tout ça on
regarde tout ça et puis de conrad se pose à 170 m
de la sonde il aurait pu se poser dessus carrément
s'il avait voulu mais il se trouve qu'elle était
déjà dans un cratère à londres et que c'était
plutôt dangereux donc il a décidé de contourner un
peu le de cratères et de se poser dans un endroit
sûr 170 m là on voit son coéquipier alan bean
qui déploient des instruments scientifiques en
gros il ouvre le coffre à bagages le coffre
arrière du module lunaire et ouvre le capot
de la voiture pour sortir cette fois une station
scientifique un peu plus ambitieuse on en parlait
de deux instruments 3 avec le drapeau suisse sur
apollo 11 là il y en a tout un tas d'autres qu'on
va installer à au moins une centaine de mètres
du module lunaire et ça va être l'objet de la
première sortie sur la lune tout à l'heure les
astronautes ont fait 2h 2h30 de sortie ils n'en
font qu'une et puis repartent là ils sortent
quatre heures il rentre à bord ils dorment un
peu images et ressorte quatre heures de nouveau
avant de repartir donc première sortie ça va
être le le modèle de toutes les missions apollo
on installe la station scientifique en rien des
sismomètres et tout un tas de d'instruments qui
fonctionne avec un générateur qui est là qui va
fournir de l'énergie avec une antenne qui envoie
tout ça directement à la terre il n'y a pas besoin
des astronautes voyons le monde déploie tout ça
assez loin et à la fin de ces quatre heures on
explore un peu et ben on ne fait des découvertes
ici là c'est bizarre on dirait mini volkan c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça que les astronomes appellent
cette chose là ça fait à peu près mètres de haut
il envoie deux ou trois comme ça ils sont très
intrigués alors ça fait passer un peu à wallace
et gromit quand même avec des espèces de petits
picots nous avons l'impression que c'est peut-être
du fromage ou du beurre en fait c'est pas mis
niveau local ont évidemment on saura plus tard
que c'est des rochers qui ont été expulsées par
les cratères et puis qui ont été érodées après
par d'autres milices impacte donc ça donne
ces espèces de mont fuji miniatures et puis
les astronautes se hasarde un peu plus loin sur
un cratère qui vont voir et on voit des roches
cassé et là c'est un des premiers celle finalement
puisque il se photographier leurs ombres qui sont
démesurément longue dans le cratère savoir car
apollo 12 dès les premières minutes de la mission
les astronautes casse la caméra il a pointé vers
le soleil le détecteur est grillé c'était une
caméra couleur cette fois et donc il n'y a plus
aucune retransmission et les chaînes américaines
de télévision refusant de faire de la radio ben
ne retransmette plus rien donc cette mission est
passé complètement sous silence il n'ya que ces
photos alors y en a beaucoup plus que celle que je
vous montre mais il ya que les photos pour cette
raison de la première sortie se termine et on se
placer une photo qui a été prise à la fin de cette
première sortie et on voit que dans ce cratère qui
est partiellement à l'ombre et partiellement
ensoleillé on voit un truc là ça c'est la zone
de surveillance roi alors quand les astronautes
voit cette cette image comme ça se disent voilà
ça va être compliqué d'aller là ça a l'air très
escarpé en fait le soleil éclaire de manière très
rasante le paysage et les moindres creux et moins
de bosses sont un peu exagéré par cet éclairage
là le lendemain qu'elle va se réveiller le sol
et ce sera encore un peu plus lever et ils sont
beaucoup plus confiants pour aller voir cette
sonde il faut dormir j'ai pas de photos des
astronautes à l'intérieur j'ai essayé de demander
alan bean comment ils avaient installé leur lit
il se souvenait pas bien c'était ya longtemps et
en fait pour la première fois alors que aldrin
armstrong dormait à même le sol ils ont ils sont
restés ils sont restés quelques heures il n'avait
rien prévu pour ça là on leur a mis des hamacs et
alors ça c'est un plan d'un couple de la cabine la
femme est ici l'arrière ici et donc il y en a un
qui se met le commandant 1 go avec un hamac dans
ce sens et l'autre ici dans l'autre sens comme ça
et ils dorment comme ça mais comme on est toujours
très prudent à la nasa on leur dit vous ne retirez
pas vos scaphandre donc ils enlèvent le casque est
légal et c'est tout et en fait c'est extrêmement
inconfortable énorme quasiment pas en plus qu'on
aura dans ce cas fans qui est mal réglé à des
sangles qui le kilo si ça c'est ça c'est difficile
mais c'est comme ça que dorénavant les astronautes
auront d'ivoire qu'est sur la lune toutes les
missions suivantes ça va être ça il faut voir que
c'est un espace extrêmement exigu et ça va être
leur lieu de vie là demain on repart comme film
noir et blanc mais vous voyez je vous montre cette
trace je peux pas vous raconter tout c'est écrit
dans mon bouquin mais cette trace là elle est un
astronaute qui a martian soulève quelque chose qui
est un peu blanc du sable comme ça qui est blanc
et l'autre lui dit mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça est en fête on a choisi cet endroit aussi parce
que c'est un des fameux rayon du grand cratère
copernic je sais pas s'il ya des astronomes
amateurs dans la salle mais c'est un des gros
cratère lunaire assez jeune avec tout autour des
rayons blanc et ses rayons blanc c'est des roches
qui ont été éjectés lors de l'impact le cratère
copernic et à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
l'endroit où s'est posé apollo 12 mai en soupçonne
que si on va là et qu'on trouve de ce matériau
blanc gonds pour adapter le cratère copernic non
on fait déjà de l'exploration de la science et
quand ils voient ce matériau blanc là qui sort
et il a ramassé un peu et on le l'analysera sur
terre on l'adaptera 810 millions d'années c'est
comme ça qu'on date le cratère copernic alors
s'il ya des gens qui se demandent de l'intérêt
d'aller sur la lune encore aujourd'hui ce serait
quand même peut-être mieux d'avoir un morceau du
cratère à copernic lui-même parce que il ya quand
même un doute non mais c'est comme ça quand même
qu'on peut en échantillonnant un endroit si on
s'y prend d'une manière assez carré arriver à
avoir des renseignements sur d'autres endroits et
là c'est la première randonnée hors du feu comment
dire du champ de la caméra qui est cassé donc elle
sert pas à grand chose et s'éloignent un peu on
doit avoir plusieurs cratères vous voyez que la
sas et le lem qui est là l'astronaute qui est ici
est quand même assez loin et si vous regardez
bien le module lunaire on ne voit pas l'entier
alors ça a l'air plat comme ça qu'on se pose sur
la lune sur cet endroit là mais le fait que nous
sommes visibles qu'à moitié ça montre qu'il ya
déjà des ondulations et seul m là il fait sept
mètres de haut enfin donc ça veut près il y au
moins une ondulation qui fait la moitié de ça et
ça commence à perdre un peu les astronautes
et ils ont des difficultés à se repérer là
quand ils voient ce cratère il avait envisagé de
descendre alors il avait il s'est équipé comme
tintin il y avait une corde au cas où il y en
a un qui encore dit m quelqu'un qui descend et
qui pourrait qu'ils puissent pas remonter on est
très prudents quand puis de conrad arrive devant
ce cratère il ne va pas descendre la réalité
on verra plus tard que les dernières missions
avec la confiance qui s'accumulent il aurait pu
descendre s'était pas dangereux mais là on fait
on fait attention on découvre je montre cette
photo qui épate révèle parce que ils découvrent
aussi autre chose des astronautes sur la lune
c'est que quand on va dans la direction opposée
au soleil on voit l'ombre de l'astronaute qui
donne exactement la direction opposée au soleil
le sable lunaire renvoie une lumière comme ça qui
fait d'ailleurs que la pleine lune est beaucoup
plus brillantes en proportion que les jours
précédents il ya un espèce de halo qui se créent
un halo anti solaire et il n'y a aucune ombre
alors là évidemment convient peu d'angle sur le
bord on voit les ombres des cailloux mais si vous
êtes ici y'a aucune ombre c'est éblouissant et il
n'avait cherché des cratères dans ces conditions
là alan bean que j'ai eu la chance d'interviewer
médiévale et il n'y a pas de pancartes avec les
noms des cratères nous on a des cartes qui sont
des vues orbital et on est au niveau du sol et
ça ressemble pas du tout donc il faut tenter de
trouver son chemin jusqu'au cratère qui ont été
désignés par les géologues pour les explorer mais
il arrive bien parce que pete conrad un très
grand sens de l'orientation et finalement même
si eux sur le moment il doute complètement
de l'android on s'apercevra plus tard qu'ils
sont passés exactement on leur avait demandé ça
c'est une vue qui est prise depuis le sud du du
lem ils font grands tours comme ça et leur trouve
qu'on voit ici c'est le cratère surveillants ou
va se trouver la somme de puisque le but c'est
quand même d'aller ramener un trophée ramené un
morceau de la sonde pour montrer qu'on a été au
bon endroit à cet endroit l'astronaute qui était
beaucoup plus facétieux que lors de la mission
précédente armstrong aldrin et collins était comme
il se définissait selon les mots de collins des
immeubles étrangers d'ailleurs hésité sympa entre
mais en dehors du boulot il n'allait pas boire
un coup ensemble e l'aller 3-2 cette émission
là c'était des des potes qui allait tout le temps
ensemble ils avaient la même voiture il sortait au
même endroit donc il avait toujours envie de
faire bien des choses qui les amuse et et la
bim et conrad ont décidé d'amener un retardateur
qui s'était en option sur les appareils photos de
l'époque ça se clipser dessus pour pouvoir poser
le l'appareil sur leur trousse à outils à 20 pieds
pour l'heure l'appareil photo m le retardateur
et faire à la première photo où ils seraient
deux sur la photo parce qu'il ya toujours un qui
photographient l'autre et au moment de chercher
c'est de chercher le retardateur qu'ils avaient
misée chacun sait qu'un échantillon s'est perdu
au milieu des roches ils perdent du temps à
houston évidemment on ne sait pas qu'il ya
ce petit programme parallèle donc ils se parlent
un langage codé tu as le truc oui non mais je ne
trouve pas attendre un peu bon il peut pas faire
patienter les gens trop longtemps comme ils ne
trouvent pas finir le mal passe à autre chose
et ils ne font pas leur leur selphy à deux nous
voyez always le module lunaire qui est posée
à 170 mètres de là et c'est la première fois
et la seule fois qu'on se promène que déjà il
se promène sur des paysages sur un paysage de
planétaire et qui a été photographié auparavant
par une sonde c'est à dire que les chercheurs
qui voulaient avoir tel roche qui était sur la
photo qui s'est totalement inaccessible plus
demandés aux astronautes d'aller la chercher
de la ramener sur terre ça je vous montre le
parcours parce que l'intéressé ça gémit à la même
échelle apollo 11 et apollo 12 le lait mais là le
plus loin qu'ils sont allés c'est ici en passant
par là on voit les traces c'est toujours une
photo de l hérault la sonde lunar reconnaissance
orbiter la zone de surveillance 3 qui est là et
retour à la base c'est à peu près la même échelle
j'essaie de me mettre à la même échelle 100 m 50
m envoyer ça c'est les 50 m armstrong ça a pris 3
minutes la deuxième sortie à le prend 4 heures et
elle est entièrement consacré à la géologie
après apollo 12 on sait qu'on peut aller de
l'avant qu'on peut utiliser les ressources que
quelles qu aient leurs réserves d'oxygène en a
quelle marge de sécurité on a à quelle vitesse
les astronautes bouge à pied sur les scaphandres
qu'ils soient encore une fois très rigide et donc
il arrive ce qui nous arrive à tous qu'on apprend
quelque chose et comprendre un peu confiance on
commence à commettre une erreur je sais pas si
vous vous faites la première fois du patinage
du patin à glace au début c'est très hésitant
vous faites très attention à pas tomber des coûts
conseil allez vous prenez confiance et c'est là
couteau mais parce que trop confiants donc apollo
14 c'est une mission qui arrive après la fameuse
apollo 13 en 1970 qui a failli ne pas arriver sur
la lune à cause d'un réservoir qui a explosé et
qui a mis en danger les astronautes vont ils ont
fait le tour de la lune ils ont réussi à revenir
sur terre vivante qui était un exploit dont il ya
eu un petit temps de délai avant de relancer pour
le 14 mai donc en janvier février 1971 apollo 14
on repart avec le même objectif qui était assigné
pour lot xiii à savoir une zone un peu plus
difficile pour se poser vous voyez le paysage
il est plus aussi plat que sur les deux premières
missions il ya des montagnes on a confiance dans
le matériel on commence à aller un endroit un peu
plus intéressant alors je passais très rapidement
sa c3 photos qui vous résume la première sortie
schéma classique les astronautes parte là ça vous
donne une idée de la qualité de la caméra
de télévision elle était pas terrible non
ils sont chargés comme avec des haltères la dalle
est déployée une station scientifique comme voilà
en partie de faire des expériences scientifiques
sur le sol lunaire là par exemple c'est un espèce
de match au bout de ce match il ya des petites
charges explosives l'insolente lemay contre le
sol ça a déclenché des petits séismes qui sont
enregistrés par des capteurs et qui permettent
de sonder comme ça l'intérieur de la de la croûte
lunaire bref quatre heures pour déployer tout ça
c'est il ya beaucoup de matériel beaucoup de
boulot à sortir c'est compliqué faut voir que
c'est quand même pas facile dans un scaphandre
mais l'objectif de cette mission l'objectif
géologique vous voyez sur la photo de l hérault
le lem s'est posée là la station scientifique a
été déployé ici le but c'est ça c'est ce cratère
qui est comme je me disais au début unis doit
faire à peu près 700 m 2 de diamètre c'est un
forage naturel quand des météorites tombent sur
un corps céleste et le creuse et vous avez toutes
les roches qui sont sorties qui sont éjectés tout
autour du cratère celles qui sont sur le bord du
cratère par exemple ici et bien sûr celles qui
viennent de plus profonde et plus on s'éloigne
plus on a les couches qu'ils sont affleurantes
donc l'idée c'est de partir du module lunaire
à pied jusque au bord du cratère pour ramasser
des roches et revenir dans l'intervalle on
doit s'arrêter à plein d'endroits parce que
les scientifiques eux sur les photos de l'époque
voit des différences deux teintes dont qui pensent
que c'est les différences d'éjectas de couches
géologiques et c'est donc il ya tout un programme
à suivre et ça ça fait environ un kilomètre et
demi avec sa rivale plus vu du sol ce qu'on a
vu c'est évident orbite salaires à ses salaires
assez plat salaire sans difficulté vu du sol ça
donne ça on sait passe pas non plus les alpes
ou les pyrénées le cratère il est quelque part
au sommet de cette colline cas l'air gentille et
douce et donc après une nuit à bord du lem où les
astronautes ont peur que le lem bascule ce qu'en
fait ils sont posées un peu de travers comme ça
ils sont pas rassurés alors il met même à donner
un espèce de fouet de suspension pour faire un
fil à plomb pour voir si c'est pas en train de
bouger tout doucement ils sont quinze voyons on
gagne la confiance mais très progressivement donc
shepard et mitchell qui sont les deux astronautes
partis alors là on a une caméra de télévision qui
fonctionne mais elle fx allait posé sur un trépied
reliées à un fil au hall m il n'est pas question
de l'emporter avec soi et ça c'est une image de
la caméra de télé qui est dirigé vers le soleil la
colline et là il ya un astronaute et un autre on
les voit comme ça partir aider qui disparaissent
au chant l'immense l'image reste totalement fixe
alors là on n'a pas cassé l'image de thé dans
la casse et la retransmission télévisée parce
que là aussi les chaînes américaines dès que ça
reste fixe comme ça pendant des heures il passe
à autre chose ils passent pas ceux des séries
c'est beaucoup plus il ya beaucoup plus action
les astronautes repartent et malgré l'expérience
d'apollo 12 là il découvre aussi que au bout de
quelques dizaines de mètres on voit que le
lait mais allait renforcer comme ça et il ya
des ondulations qui ne voient pas le terrain à
leur place mais il ne l'est pas du tout et cette
image elle vous montre edgar mitchell en train de
faire quoi en train de regarder la carte comme un
randonneur qui se serait perdu dans le brouillard
des montagnes parce que ils doivent comme je vous
l'aï dit tout à l'heure à trouver des endroits
spécial spéciaux pardon défini à l'avancé ou
collecter des échantillons et alors ils sont
ils sont perdus sont pas perdus aux points ne
pas savoir retrouver leur chemin ils sont capables
de revenir au module lunaire mais ils sont perdus
dans le sens où ils sous-estiment les distances et
ça c'est un effet que eux découvrent encore plus
de manière plus criante que les astronautes à pour
le 12 c'est vrai qu'en gros systématiquement ils
pensent qu'ils sont au bon endroit et en fait
ils sont à la moitié de la distance qu'ils ont
couvert alors ils ont bien des techniques avec
le pouce pour imagine par rapport aux modules
lunaires pour essayer de de sa d'évaluer à quel
existe en six ans il se trouve mais en fait sur
la lune n'y a pas d'atmosphère et cette atmosphère
qui est sur terre quand on se promène par exemple
la montagne même si elle est très clair si vous
avez des montagnes qui sont très éloignées elles
vont être quand même toujours un peu plus dans
la brume que celles qui sont au premier plan
et ça ça vous donne déjà une indication de la
distance sur la lune il n'y a pas d'arbres il n'y
a pas de voiture il n'y a pas de maison toutes ces
choses qui sont familières et qui nous permettent
d'évaluer les distances la seule chose qui leur
permet d'évaluer la distance et le module lunaire
alors de tintin ne le voit pas et puis quand il
regarde dans d'autres directions il n'est pas
dans leur champ de vision donc en gros ils se
perdent ils se perdent aussi sur la direction
ils montent à l'horizon voyez là c'est une espèce
de brouette pour transporter leurs outils et pour
mettre échantillons alors c'est bien c'est mieux
que précédemment donc là il s'arrête à faire des
mesures et vous voyez qu'il monte contre le soleil
là on voit shepard qui est en train de tirer ce
sa brouette d'un soulève de la poussière et
ça monte et ça commence à devenir difficile
la boîte et carottes beaucoup sur les sur les
rochers donc au bout d'un moment tous les deux ils
apprennent m par chaque aube où il la porte pour
que ça aille mieux mais ça monte et leur rythme
cardiaque qui a enregistré à houston parce qu'ils
ont des capteurs biométriques reçu ses alentours
de 140 ça qu'on leur dit de faire des pauses etc
ils sont pas d'accord sur la direction où aller
pour alors il se hisse le chic un peu à houston
on n'ose pas trop leur donner les directives et e
s'acharne à essayer de trouver les bons endroits
que les scientifiques ont prédéterminé etc bref
on perd beaucoup de temps à l'aller et au final
ils arrivent à cet endroit où il ya beaucoup de
cailloux on se doute bien que le cratère qu'il
cherchait n'est pas très loin puisque c'est sans
doute des morceaux éjecté mais ils ne le voient
pas alors il se disait mais tant pis on considère
qu'on est à côté du cratère et on va collecter
les rochers il voit cette roche qui est un peu
blanche donc ils vont vers là c'est cet euro cela
est allé ici sur la photo de l hérault vous voyez
que le cratère comment cela entre la et là il ya
17 mètres et ils ne voient pas le gros cratère
et qui sont venus voir parce que il est sur une
colline et il est sur le dévers sur un versant de
l'autre côté donc il ne voit pas le côté opposé et
ils sont extrêmement frustré après s'être un peu
chamaillés sur la direction ils ont plus de temps
en termes de marge de sécurité il faut rentrer
parce que sinon il y aura plus assez d'oxygène en
cas de problème est en fait sur cette photo là je
voulais mise là parce que ces roches et là c'est
exactement le bord du cratère dons qui sont passés
très près de l'objectif en réalité ils ont atteint
l'objectif sans avoir sans bénéficier du paysage
qu aurait été fantastique voire à l'intérieur
du cratère alors on a beaucoup critiqué cette
mission apollo 14 parce que alan shepard qui a
été le premier américain dans l'espace en 1961
et c'est quand même un gars de l'étoffé des
héros il est il a un gros ego contrairement
à enstone qui n'en a pas michel bailly les il
s'éteint c'est un novice il a jamais fait de
vol spatial et tous les deux finalement ce sont
pas très bons élèves là on voit des astronautes
à l'entraînement ici à john young et charlie duke
qui sont dans la mission de la polo c'est ce dont
je vous parlerai brièvement après ils sont sur
un terrain pour apprendre dans la géologie si
les bons élèves les très bons élèves s'est dit
mauvais les frais days d'apollo 13 malheureusement
leur vaisseau ne leur a pas permis d'arriver
sur la lune et les mauvais élèves en terme de
géologie séché par deux convois au centre la
voyais alors j'ai pris cette photo exprès vous
savez combien sur les journalistes ont bien les
choses en spectaculaire alors je l'enfance un peu
lâché pas parce qu'il a un regard un regard de ces
roches de travers dans une mine à l'entraînement
sur terre et michel boy semble pas très intéressé
avec ses mains dans les poches et sa casquette
de baseball heures donc ses astronautes là on le
sait la géologie c'est vraiment pas leur passion
mais une fois sur place moi j'ai j'ai travaillé
sur cette mission là je leur rends quand même
hommage parce que une fois sur place ils ont fait
vraiment du bon travail et si cette mission apollo
14 en un peu et shui et échoué à ramasser les
échantillons dans les bonnes conditions il ya tout
un tas de procédure il faut prendre les photos
avant/après etc s'ils ont perdu du temps c'est
aussi parce que les équipes au sol on découvert
que l'exploration mais ça ne marchait pas comme
on l'avait prévu ils ont appris mais on apprend
souvent en faisant des erreurs il aurait fallu
qui drive un peu mieux les astronautes depuis le
sol lui alors laisser perdre du temps à l'aller
il fallait qu'ils aillent au plus loin et puis
faire les objectifs secondaires au retour c'est
ce qui se fera dans les missions suivantes donc
la faute de la mauvaise collecte d'échantillons
sur apollo 14 ne revient pas finalement à alan
shepard qui lui a beaucoup insisté pour coller
aux objectifs des scientifiques mais à l'ensemble
à lui n'attend pas ce qui s'est passé entraîné
quand même mais aussi aux scientifiques qui sur
le moment on pas gérer l'exploration comme il le
fallait même temps ci comme ça qu'on apprend c'est
en faisant des erreurs dans la salle de contrôle
alors voilà le tout le trajet dans la salle de
contrôle d'apollo 14 il y à un homme qui est le
mil commandant de la mission suivante qui apollo
15 david scott qui est ici sur la jeep lunaire une
fois sur terre enfin pour la pour l'entraîneur
ron qui dit ça n'arrivera pas sur ma mission en
fait ce cafouillage la n'arrivera pas il voit ce
qui se passe il voit cette perte de temps et lui
par contre c'est un très bon élève il a été formé
par un géologue qui s'appelle li silver et il va
appliquer à fond tout ce qu'on lui a appris
sur le terrain la géologie je crois qu'il a
eu il a passé des diplômes pourra en géologie
venir c'est à ses capés et il veut absolument
que sa mission soit exemplaire il veut redorer le
blason de l'exploration sur la lune et pour ça on
lui laisse le choix du site atterrissage il a le
choix entre deux sites un peu comme le précédent
avec des collines et celui ci n'est il pas celui
ci parce que c'est compliqué il dit moi je vais
aller me posez là alors là c'est pas simplement
intéressant géologiquement parce que vous voyez
qu'il ya une espèce de deux fleuves alors spam
fleuve d'eau c'est ainsi un fleuve de l'avs parce
que toute cette plaine lassé de la lave qui a été
solidifiée il ya ça il ya des montagnes autour
alors c'est très intéressant parce que ça peut
être des morceaux de la croûte primitive de la
lune qui sauve la même temps que du volcanisme
récent était donc scientifiquement c'est
intéressant mais ce qui intéresse encore plus
david scott c'est que si spectaculaire et surtout
c'est difficile pour un pilote parce que le lem va
arriver par là et va se poser là ces montagnes là
son antre 4005 et 3500 mètres altitude cela doit
être 4000 employés dont il faut passer aura comme
ça la tête en l'air les montagnes dans le dos il
faut avoir confiance nos latitudes all-in on l'y
voit pas et sitôt qu'on a passé les montagnes hop
on se pose verticalement et dès qu'il faut cette
manoeuvre de pilotage comme ça et autres otages
ils s'aperçoivent que pratiquement les sommets sur
même niveau que donc c'est très impressionnant
c'est une prouesse de pilotes et en même temps
c'est un objectif prestigieux il pense david scott
que l'homme doit explorer et que ça doit se voir
il tient absolument à ce que on s'intéresse que
le grand public s'intéresse à cette émission
alors voilà le lem poser avec une des montagnes
derrière et lui il veut faire ce que son mentor
en géologie lee silver lui a dit c'est observer
d'abord le paysage avant de se lancer dedans et
donc cette flèche contre le sommet du lem pas
ce qu'est une trappe qui permet uniquement de
passer du lem à la capsule apollo une fois que la
mission est terminée ou pour rentrer le lem et la
nasa veut pas qu'on ouvre cette trappe quand on
est sur lui ni aucun sens en fait lui il a insisté
il obtient qu'on louvre et ils montent comme ça
par la trappe il se met avec les coudes comme
ça et il fait des photos cette photo sam est une
qui permet de voir les environs et de commencer
à faire une description et géologiques il dispose
aussi d'un outil majeur par rapport à pour le 14
ou les shepard et mitchell ont fait un kilomètre
et demi à l'aller un kilomètre de mire retour il
était épuisé et il avait un scaphandre très rigide
là le scaphandre et mieux mais en plus ils ont ça
une jeep lunaire qui va leur permettre d'aller à
5 6 ou 7 km du lem alors évidemment des corners
aux transports les paysages changent assez vite
et là lors de la première excursion l'a dit plus
leur va jusqu au pied d'une montagne et en même
temps au pied ou au bord de cette fameuse rivière
de lave a asséché alors ici on voit des cailloux
et ça c'est la même zone méprise un objectif avec
un objectif de 500 mm donc un zoom et il faut
savoir que ces cailloux la font à peu près la
taille de mes hommes et que en gros la vallée fait
un kilomètre de large lors de la deuxième sortie
je vous passe le développement et le déploiement
des désastres humains destinés à sonder la lune
il y avait notamment une foreuse qui marche pas il
s'escrime épaisse qui perdent énormément de temps
en fait l'instrument est mal conçu donc ça marche
pas lors de la deuxième sortie il volé sur les
pentes du mont châtelet delta qui est qui culmine
à 3500 mètres alors ils vont pas faire toute la
grimpette parce que c'est un peu raide quand même
c'est pas prévu au programme on est quand même
encore un peu friable mais on voit des panoramas
comme ça j'assemble est ici plusieurs photos le
lem a dû se poser quelque part par là ils sont à
cinq kilomètres on voit les traces de leur jeep on
voit le monde appelait qui est ici à 4500 mètres
on voit ici la rivière de lave qui est là la
première sortie sont allés jusqu ici et ils sont
à flanc de colline et aux 500 mm il ya des photos
incroyables comme ça à cinq kilomètres de là il
photographie leur maison qui est posée là bas
c'est le seul spots de couleurs malheureusement
n'y avait que du film noir et blanc à ce moment
là mais cette photo est vraiment incroyable on
voit la seule le seul outil technologique humains
dans un monde totalement minérale et là je vous
montre une séquence est qui est un peu difficile
à voir mais les astronautes progresse à flanc de
colline le long qui mentent pas ils descendent pas
ils sont à de travers quand même ce à l'horizon
à l'air plat comme ça ils veulent aller voir un
rocher qui sont je suis ici c'est de trouver des
rochers en trouve pas beaucoup et voyez ici en
fait les collines l'ouvré horizon il est comme
ça donc en fait sont inclinés vraiment vraiment
beaucoup et il faut cette petite petits trajets
cette image est enregistré avec une caméra 16 mm
donc c'est pas envoyé en direct s'est développée
après la mission donc à houston en juste l'audio
en talent c'est assez c'est très petit mot plus
ambitieux est pas bonne voie là où s'arrête avec
eux quand on s'arrête l'horizontale c'est là hélas
assez là c'est la pente et à houston on n'a pas
conscience de landreau me sow en fait ils sont
très très très incliné comme ça les astronautes
décembre erwin décent et il comprend qu'il aura du
mal à remonter tellement sympa par un hôtel à la
voiture scott dessin essaie d'orienter l'antenne
de transmission delà de la caméra de télévision
parce que celle ci est embarqué dans la rover
et permet de suivre les astronautes partout où
ils vont elles mêmes pilotable depuis la terre
il ya un opérateur qui peut zoomer qui peut la
diriger donc c'est déjà un peu plus hollywoodien
les premières les premières missions donc là on
voit scott qui est descendue qui essaie d'orienter
l'antenne en fait c'est tellement bon qu'il arrive
ne pas viser la terre donc il dit à hugo broos
finalement ça me prend trop de ta joue mais pas
la transmission on n'a pas de problème et ensuite
on entend les astronautes qui ont des des échanges
un peu bizarre il est bon mais je leur avais
ailleurs et c'est ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est
qu'à ce moment-là d'avis quand remonte sur la
voiture effet la première marche arrière sur
la lune alors ça a l'air de rien comme ça l'est
avec le scaphandre et pourquoi tourner la tête
il a évidemment pas de rétroviseur donc à houston
on subodore qu'il se passe quelque chose on sait
pas trop quoi donc là il est toujours en train
d'essayer d'installer l'antenne et finalement il
renoncera et finalement il va s'avérer un peu
plus bas son coéquipier l'ont rejoint mais ça
glisse beaucoup et on leur pose des questions
mais vous êtes surtout cependant j'ai tellement
fait pas alors tout va bien on le prend le temps
tranquille et quand il se regarde une deuxième
fois il sent que le rover commence à glisser le
traverse comme ça dans le sens de la partie et il
dit à son coéquipier j'ai ici bien tenir le rover
parce que j'ai peur de le perdre alors ils se
tournent en temps on n'est qu'à 1 radio on attend
ça et eux ils ont pas ils ont pas dans la voie des
trémolos qui font qu'on se dit ils ont peur mais
quand même un peu inquiet et il ya une photo qui
existent de ce moment là alors ça c'est vous et
demi l'inclinaison d'un réel de la séquence vidéo
que vous venez voir l'horizon est là donc on voit
qu'on quelle est la pente là ils sont arrêtés près
de ce caillou que david scott voulait absolument
voir donc et là il est là et jim irwin lui il
tient le rover là et on voit que la la rougeole
touche pas par terre et tout se passe très bien
il ramène les roches et au moins de rembarquer
alors il toujours pas d'imagés là ils renoncent
à leur envoyer les images avant de rembarquer il
dit à irin bon maintenant pousse toi c'est jamais
tu vas descendre je te reprendre un peu plus bas
parce qu'il fait toujours pas monté vu que c'est
trop en pente et il ya une photo qui est prise un
peu plus loin où les astronautes étaient là voyez
au bout de la flèche la ici ça c'est le fameux
rocher là on devine les traces de roues alors si
on pouvait la voir à voir zoom on les verrait donc
là il repart il récupère irwin à peu près ici donc
l'autre est descendu un peu à pied et on voit le
trajet jusqu'au prochain endroit et le prochain en
droit finalement la roche d'un mois n'était pas si
intéressante que ça l'endroit suivant est beaucoup
plus intéressant il ya ce petit caillou la bizarre
avec un espèce de des blancs qui cause et qui est
posée là et c'est cette roche ils en sont sûrs
au moment où il la voit pas ce qu'ils ont bien
bossé la géologie 6 assassin bout d'anorthosite
alors je vais pas vous détailler ce que c'est
mais en gros c'est un bout de roche primitive de
la croûte lunaire c'est pas tout à fait primitive
elle sera daté à 4,1 milliards d'années donc la
lune à 85 c pas là tout primitivement tout cas
c'est des premières roche de la la première
croûte lunaire et c'est ce qu'ils sont venus
chercher et la presse toujours prompte à titrer
de manière un peu sensationnelle vous le savez
va appeler cette roche la roche de la genèse
gras niveau qu'un coup ça c'est bien vous avez
avec hubble par exemple quand ils veulent aller
photographier une nébuleuse avec des espèces de
deux piliers l'intérieur appelait ça les piliers
de la création donc la nasa apprend qu'elle m'a
communiqué à l'époque est donc cette gauche là
raconte une partie de l'histoire de la lune et
vous voyez que cette photo de groupe là on voit
les traces des pas ici il ya un espèce de gnome
ont ici qui donne la verticale il ya un nuancier
de couleurs pour pouvoir interpréter on voit le
contexte avant collecte ils ont pris les mêmes
photos après et c'est donc il faut ça vraiment
de dollars et puis il rentre alors en fait il
faut savoir que là je vous laisse ces images
parce qu'elles sont assez extraordinaire c'est de
retour vera vers la base ces caméras embarquées
comme on peut voir ça vous formulez par exemple
les astronautes ont quand même donc arrêté sur un
site qui est vraiment très intéressant parce que
les montagnes cdc des roches qui ont été excavées
nos plus profonds de la lune et ils ont trouvé
ce qu'ils venaient chercher ils sont vraiment en
train de donner aux scientifiques les moyens
d'explorer le passé non seulement de la lune
mais aussi de la terre et puis de tout le système
solaire à l'envoyer qu'ils suivent pour revenir à
la maison ils suivre leurs traces de roues comme
les dupont dans le désert c'est toujours une
histoire de tintin mais là en fait ils n'ont pas
besoin de ça ils le font c'est pratique mais ils
ont un petit système qui leur permet de naviguer
de savoir où était le lem auparavant voilà les
fameuses images de rover lunaire alors ils vont
aussi de nouveaux investiguer près de la dune
de la rivière de lave asséchés voilà un peu les
excursions qui font la première ici la deuxième
la et la troisième qui est pas marqué jusqu ici et
là on voit la différence entre apollo 15 apollo ça
pour le 14 avril au 15 scott voulait le marqué du
sceau de la science il réussit à la fin vous avez
les astronautes ont toujours quelques moments
où une minute ou deux où ils peuvent se laisser
un peu aller avant david scott se laisse
pas aller il prend dans une main un marteau
dans l'autre une plume plus de faucon et il va
aller laisser tomber les deux simultanément il
va refaire à une expérience scientifique celle
qui avait été prédite c'était une expérience
de pensée par galilée vers 1610 où normalement en
l'absence d'atmosphère si on lâche la gravitation
la force de gravité s'exerce aussi bien sur le
marteau que sur la plume et les deux doivent
normalement de tomber ou même un moment d'entrer
en contact avec le sol au même moment puisqu'ils
vont être attirés avec la même vitesse est ici
si on la fait évidemment la plume flotte parce
qu'elle prend appui sur l'air et donc voilà il
dit voyons si galilée avait raison et ouais ça
marche donc il voulait vraiment marcher faire
en tout cas de la pédagogie pour pour le grand
public et d'ailleurs scott sera un peu fâché
je crois qu'il voulait ramener la plume mais
l'un d'eux aura marcher dessus il faut dire
que les astronautes ne voient pas leur pied
avec les scaphandres un peu compliqué à côté
de ça je reviens juste sur apollo 14 qu'on a
beaucoup critiqué que j'ai un peu défendu de mon
bouquin mine de rien alors que moi aussi j'étais
je me disais je sépare il n'a pas bien fait le
job donc je lui rend justice shepard lui qu'il
lui reste deux minutes à la fin alors l'image est
moins bonne c'était une mission précédente de la
caméra était moins bien c'est très saturé j'ai
parlé ici et vous allez voir qu'il ya un truc
brillante dans les mains en fait c'est un tube de
forage auxquels il a ajouté un fer 7 pour ceux qui
jouent au golf c'est un il a transformé donc en
club de golf et rend sa poche et qu'il a sur le
genou il ya deux balles de golf donc il décide de
taper deux balles de golf sur la lune pour avoir
une première et donc vous voyez qu'il ya quand
même une petite dichotomie entre le message qui
est envoyé par david scott est celui qui a envoyé
par alan shepard d'autant qu'après voilà or là ils
tapent pas très satisfait en fait il a surtout
soulevé de la terre il a tapé dans la mode mais
c'est pas facile parce qu'il ne peut le faire et
avec une main ne peut pas faire le ska fans encore
une fois trop rigide il ya une il retape une
deuxième fois et puis là ça va un peu plus loin
mais il est pas satisfait donc ça se fera mais
un bal qui avait pas bougé et convaincant assez
adroit l'annoncé par dylan envoie une autre celle
là ça va marcher il va l'envoyer à ses ruelles il
va dire miles en fait il un peu vantard s'était
pas aller aussi loin que sauf mais il a réussi
son coup et il a réussi aussi à se mettre à dos
les scientifiques à peu de frais alors apollo
14 était le temps des erreurs a pour le 16 c'est
un peu la même chose mais c'est toujours du côté
des chercheurs finale avant que ça pêche parce
que là on décide de se poser dans cette région
bon on voit déjà petite colline peut être des
endroits où c'est plutôt plat avec le cratère
en fait quand vous regardez la lune même à l'oeil
nu pas besoin d'un télescope vous constatez qu'il
ya des zones qui sont blanches et des zones
qui sont plus sombres zones qui sont un peu
plus sombre ces raisons les plus récentes de
la lune sont des épanchements de lave ce qu'on
appelle les mers lunaires et les zones blanches
c'est a priori ce qui est plus ancien et jusqu'à
présent à part apollo 14 qui s'est posé dans
ce qu'on croyait être une zone blanche donc les
highlands les hautes terres de l'ancienne croûte
lunaire mais c'était panne est en fait c'est un
éjecteur de notre cratère donc c'est pas net a
pour le cese lui alors ça paraît pas sur cette
photo pascal et un gros plan c'est pile au milieu
d'une zone viandes blanches et cette zone a été
explorée deux piles orbite par stuart rose alors
de la mission apollo 14 sa caméra mal marché donc
il a fait avec un zoom à la main c'est un peu
flou tout ça donc la qualité des photos était
pas terrible et les scientifiques ont bâti leur
interprétation savoir qu'à l'époque on n'a pas
cartographier toutes la lune en cartographie
que au dessus de l'orbité équatoriale de là où
passent les missions apollo donc on fait avec
ce qu'on a ils ont ça ils veulent quand même
aller dans les highlands dans les zones claires
et la résolution n'est pas très bonne mais de ce
qu'il voit cette résolution la leur font penser
qu'ils ont peut-être là les premiers volcans de
la lune les prix et les volcans primitif
ceux qui ont percé la croûte initial de la
lune évidemment ramener des laves de cet endroit
là serait formidable donc on envoie à john young
et charlie duke exploré cet endroit on se dit
que on va pouvoir aller faire un tour sur cette
montagne on est à la confluence de deux zones
qui ont l'air différentes là il ya un cratère
qu'intéressant là il ya un autre et c'est donc
tout ça à l'air bien dans les cases iman sûr on a
une hypothèse de travail mais une seule c'est une
région volcanique et donc les astronautes autour
de leur procurer leur première excursion là cette
fois depuis pour l'occasion fait trois excursions
non pas de deux de quatre heures mais trois de
sept heures ont passé trois nuits sur la lune donc
on vit vraiment sur la lune première excursion
on va voir une zone avec un cratère alors là
pour la petite histoire la flèche se montre la
caméra de télévision qui prend ça au moment où
on lui prend la photo clic et cette photo c'est
ça dont vous avez l'anglais l'angle opposé clin
d'oeil mais dès que les astronautes arrivés sur
le sol de cette région de ce qu'ils ont appris
de la géologie rappelez-vous young et duke duke
c'est les bons élèves j'ai donc ça me connaissent
un rayon ils disent nous des roches basaltiques
on n'en voit pas on voit que des brèches c'est à
dire des des mélanges de météorites et de roches
lunaires un fondu sous les impacts et donc ils
sont embêtés parce que ça pas l'air de coller
avec ce que les scientifiques attendent et la
deuxième flèche vous montre un caillou qu'on voit
la barre et que les gens à houston repères et 10
de le prendre alors l'astronaute n'arrive pas à le
prendre et qui s'appelle charlie duke parce qu'il
a l'air petit ce caillou depuis houston mais une
fois qu'ils s'approchent en fait il est gros parce
que comme un ballon peut-être de handball quelque
chose comme ça on ouvre à s'agenouiller au risque
de tomber le cratère donc ils font des petites
blagues reçu j'espère que ce caillou en vaut
le coup parce que si je trouve dans la renverse
on voudrait pas me chercher c'est mais en gros
apollo 16 pour faire rapide c'est une émission
où on s'est trompé d'objectif et où finalement
on a vu que des brèches on n'a pas vu les premiers
volkan de la lune et là je vous montre un document
qui est exceptionnel que vous avez peut-être
déjà vu mais là il a été retravaillé par déjà
récemment vous voyez que le cadre bouge et en fait
l'astronaute charlie duke qui qui montrent qu'ils
filment la la jeep lunaire en train de bouger
lui bouge aussi donc ça ferait sautiller là on a
recentré sur la bible ce qui fait que l'image est
stable et c'est ce que la nasa appelée le grand
prix lunaire parce qu'il fallait quand même que
pour les ingénieurs on montre la jeep en train de
rouler sur la lune pour voir comment ça marche et
sur apollo 15 la caméra avait pas marché donc il
refonde voyez que là il va maximum à 10 kilomètres
à l'heure et qu'il arrive à faire des dérapages
et a envoyé des tas de poussière dans le l'espace
en fait ça s'est un peu plus tard dans la mission
qu'il revienne vous voyez là aussi c'est pareil
tout à l'heure ça dansait beaucoup là tout a été
recentré et vous ça donne une fluidité et une
beauté à ces images parce que c'était prix en
16 mm ce qui les gens format très flatteur pour
l'époque et la définition est vraiment étonnante
voyez que ça capte pas mal quand même qu'en se
base sur la rue puisqu'il n'y a pas de route
les astronautes fonds records c'est eux qui ont le
plus gros dénivelés aux alpinistes de la lumière
en voiture leur module lunaire et quelque part
dans la plaine à la barre ici exactement il ya
cinq ou six kilomètres eux ils ont fait un
dénivelé ils ont monté avec leur avec leur
la rover environ 150 mètres au dessus ils ont
paysages fabuleux il peut vous voir donc leur
module lunaire très très loin et ce alors vraiment
alors couper le souffle sur une image aux 500 mm
on le voit ici le module lunaire mais ils peuvent
aussi faire des prévisions sur ce qu'ils vont
faire le jour suivant la troisième sortie cette
flèche montreux rochers qui vont aller explorer
on le voit ici après avoir amassé les cailloux
par là ils vont aller jusque là bas ramasser
des morceaux de ce rocher qui a été éjecté d'un
cratère il voit aussi ce rocher là qui est celui
là il faut aller là d'ailleurs charlie duke va
rester coincé dessous un moment donné la tombée
mais sans gravité et donc à pour le cese va manque
un peu son objectif mais va nous apprendre quand
même que finalement il n'y a pas de volcan comme
ça primitif sur la lune vous savez qu avant apollo
11 quand même des gens très éminentes qui avaient
des théories sur la lune notamment la théorie de
la lune froide ont pensé que c'était des cailloux
qui s'était agglomérés dans l'espace ne s'était
pas fondu que tout ça c'était gentiment aggloméré
que ça ait fini par former la lune donc quand neil
armstrong a ramené des morceaux de basalte là
ça marchait plus du tout puisque pour ce qui
est du basalte il faut que les roches fondues à
l'intérieur qui et les éruptions en quelque sorte
et que donc on est à faire encore différencier
et qui a été au moins dans sa jeunesse il a
fallu revoir absolument toutes les théories
sur la lune donc là on est en 1960 et 12 avril
1972 tout est sur la table c'est un véritable
chantier on croit toujours voir les essayer de
trouver des volcans primitif de la lune mais
là c'est raté alors pour quand les astronautes
l'iss sont posés par là les astronautes là au
bout de la flèche et ils sont monté jusque là
avec la jeep pour observer ces cratères là et
puis les gros rochers qu'on voyait il était à
côté de ce cratère et après désintérêt du public
oblige désintérêt des politiques obligent aussi
mais je suis celui du public il va pas le devant
s'est quand même les dernières missions apollo
sont depuis 1960 et 10 ont été annulés ça coûte
très cher l'envoyer homme sur la lune à la nasa
on a quand même un peu peur que ça soit le coup
de trop juste que ça jusque là tout s'est bien
passé a pour le xiii est pas passé loin du drame
on est aux limites du matériel même s'il a évolué
depuis apollo 15 le lait mais plus puissant il
a plus de réserves on a plus confiance mais on
se dit quand même s'il ya un problème ça serait
quand même bête d'avoir gagné cette course à la
lune et de finir avec par exemple trois morts donc
ça devrait aller jusqu'à paulo veine qui pouvait
éventuellement se poser à l'intérieur du cratère
copernic ça aurait été formidable apollo 20 19 et
18 sont annulés il y à un pilote qui s'appelle
john gueule qui est débarquée d'apollo 17 pour
remplacer par lui qui s'appelle harrison suite
et qui est le seul géologue le seul scientifique
parmi tous les astronautes qui sont tous des
militaires des pilotes d'essai alors ça plaît pas
au début ça plaît pas beaucoup à jean fernand qui
avait son copain jo en gueule et pour piloter le
module lunaire et qui était qui avaient beaucoup
confiance en lui parce que c'est un très bon
pilote alors que harrison schmitt est considéré
comme un pilote très moyen en fait il faudra bien
le job mais par contre sur le terrain'' c'est
un véritable professionnel de la géologie donc
il va s'en donner à coeur joie on vise un endroit
entouré de montagnes la vallée de taurus lytro ici
c'est des montagnes north massifs etc il ya des
montagnes ici à des montagnes là ce massif il ya
des montagnes partout c'est un véritable cirque
lunaire il y à issy lilin content car c'est une
drôle de vagues figé sur la lave lunaire ici on
pense que c'est peut-être toujours cette histoire
de volcan parce qu'il ya parmi ces cratères
certains ne sont pas des cratères d'impact
non parce que ce sont des cratères volcaniques
et ce qui est entouré ici la station de 6 c'est
un rocher qui a roulé un énorme rocher qui a roulé
le long de la montagne et qui vient peut-être d'un
cratère qui s'est formé beaucoup plus loin qu'il
va pouvoir l'analyse et pour analyser un autre
coin bref c'est on a choisi un endroit où il ya
beaucoup de choses à voir et on fait une peut-être
une première excursion vers l'art après avoir
installé la station scientifique mais je vous
en parle tout de suite ces scientifiques il ya un
être l'instrument qui a attiré mon attention c'est
ce truc là tout bizarre ça ressemble à une fête
c'est une petite sorte de petite balance s'appelle
le lun'art sismomètres lun'art gravity si ce
moteur est en fait c'est un détecteur donne de
gravitationnelle je sais pas si vous avez entendu
parler de ça mais en 2015 il ya des observateurs
à très sophistiquée sur terre liegault et virgo
un peu plus tard qui ont détecté pour la première
fois des zones de gravitationnelles déformations
de l'espace étant très difficile à avoir eh bien
l'époque il avait un scientifique qui s'appelait
jour webber qui a été le premier le précurseur
à vouloir détecter ces ondes gravitationnelles
là il a réussi à faire embarquer une expérience
sur la lune ce détecteur devait fonctionner en
même temps que d'autres détecteur sur terre et
détecter éventuellement entre la terre à la
lune le passage d'une onde gravitationnelle
par le changement de temps qu'ils avaient entre
les communications entre les deux instruments bon
il se trouve que on avait tellement peur que
ce détecteur soit malmené par les astronautes
fou rire qui sont toujours avec un gros scaphandre
c'est compliqué donc on leur interdit de l'essayer
sur terre dont ils savent comment le déballer mais
il n'y touche pas harrison schmitt le géologue il
est quand même sceptique sur cette histoire là
et pense que ça va leur faire perdre du temps
il déploie ce truc est au bout de la troisième
sortie à houston on lui dit il faudrait quand
même aller voir le détecteur parce qu'il semble
qu'il ya un truc qui marche pas donc il y va on
lui demande de tapoter un peu dessus il tapote
mais il est un peu sceptique aussi parce qu'on
lui avait demandé de faire attention puis on
lui dit non vas-y tu apesi vraiment dessus je
vais te sur les gars oui oui vas-y donc tape
dessus et à houston ça va pas se rendre compte
qu'il ya quelque chose qui marche pas alors on
le soupçonne d'avoir lui d'avoir mal déployés
l'engin en fait on verra plus tard que l'un gène
était mal conçu la balance est pas bien équilibrée
il ya un dixième de gramme d'un côté qui fait que
c'est pas équilibré donc ça peut pas détecter quoi
que ce soit et donc il a déployé ce truc là pour
rien ainsi qu il le redoutait alors j'ai cherché
un peu si ce truc là avait fonctionné est-ce
que les zones de gravitationnelle aurait été
découverte en 1972 et est ce que joe webber aurait
eu le prix nobel de physique et bien la réponse
est non parce que à l'époque ce détecteur là ils
étaient au moins dix fois moins sensible que les
détecteurs d'aujourd'hui et on peut penser que les
zones de gravitationnelle pouvait avoir des effets
beaucoup plus visible donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
tenté l'expérience quand même mais donc même s'il
avait fonctionné il n'aurait rien vu d'après
les chercheurs qui ont mis au point les vrais
détecteur dont deux quarts est stationnaire voilà
pour la petite histoire mais j'ignorais ça jusqu'à
ce que je m'intéresse à la mission apollo 17 bon
alors je vous passe toutes les explorations il ya
un truc qui fascine jeans hernan c'est la terre au
dessus la lune a pour logiciels s'est posé à ses
à l'est du coup la terre et patriotes dans le ciel
alors salaires plat comme ça ici en fait c'est une
montagne qui fait 2000 mètres au 1500 mètres de
hauteur donc il est au bas de la montagne il à peu
près par là où ils seront chez là c'est celui-là
sont garés ici et il est venu là faire une photo
avec la la la terre est juste en dehors du charme
malheureusement sur cette photo il la voit pas
mais il a tenu absolument à photographier la terre
depuis la lune c'est la seule photo il en a fait
une autre mais c'est la seule photo sur laquelle
on voit un paysage lunaire au sol depuis la lune
et la terre dans le même cliché vous parlais tout
à l'heure de l'espèce d'escarpements la vague qui
avait l'air solidifier la deux est bien vu de près
c'est ça et on saura je crois que ces 2011 ou 2012
que finalement les astronautes ont vu là ce qu'ils
voient là c'est une faille de compression en fait
non pas de compressions de contraction de la
lune bien que la lune qui en corse en eau quand
il s'est refroidie il a fallu qu'elle se contracte
mais ça ça coince et aux entournures c'était assez
rigide et donc sur la surface il ya des failles
qui sont créées ou la lune a perdu quelques
kilomètres de diamètre et bien ça sans le savoir
à l'époque les astronautes sont allés prendre des
échantillons sur un endroit comme ça c'est l'un
de ces endroits qui a été découvert par la sonde
lro dans les années 2010 mais qui a été explorée
comme ça par les astronautes d'apollo 17 alors
évidemment un schmid qui est un géologue rêve
de voir un volcan ça c'est les fameuses photos
mal résolu la mission pour le 14 qui montre ce
cratère et qui s'appelle shorty on voit qu'il est
tout autour avec quelque chose de sombre donc on
se disait ça c'est de la lawe cd des fontaines de
laves donc c'est peut-être un cratère volcanique
et n'ont pas d'impact en fait un cratère d'impact
mais à un moment donné car ils sont vite ici là
y'a un gros plan il voit du sol orange et saihi
crois qu'il a trouvé une fumerolle quelque chose
ici qui accrédite l'histoire du volcan en réalité
où il a trouvé c'est du volcanisme puisqu'on est
sur un sol basaltiques c'est une mère de l'aveu
là où ils se trouvent mais ça n'a rien à voir
et le cratère c'est juste des éruptions comme
ça des fontaines de lave qui ont eu lieu bien plus
tardivement il n'a toujours pas trouvé les fameux
volcan initiaux de la lune je vous parlais d'un
rocher qui avait roulé le long de la colline et
qui s'est cassé en deux là les saisissantes et aux
photos soient les l'approché comme ça c'est des
rochers qui ont été éjectés par d'autres cratère
et les paysages sont fantastiques alors là je
vous montre ils sont toujours à côté de ce rocher
j'ai mis de travers parce que c'est toujours pour
vous dans l'est la pente n'envoyez l'astronaute à
peu près verticale et pour vous dire qu'on prend
confiance dans ce baladin sauts de kangourou
comme aldrin ne l'avait expérimenté et on y va
gaiement n'a pas peur quand on n'a pas peur parce
qu'il se passe il faut rester prudent quand même
énorme à l'époque on aurait vu armstrong tomber
comme ça on aurait cru qu'il était mort en fait
là ils ont vraiment confiance les gars et ils se
rouler dans la poussière lorsqu afin d'être été
vraiment vraiment solide schmidt demandera à faire
une quatrième sortie pas une fois sur la lune mais
avant la mission ils voulaient le quatrième sortie
dans l'espace au final sur la lune pour explorer
la nasa lui dit non parce que on a peur que la
poussière qui est très abrasif sur la lune n'est
pas érodé du tout par l'eau ou par l'air c'est des
petits morceaux très anguleux sa s'immisce partout
c'est statique s'est chargée électriquement donc
ça colle ça se met sur les colliers qui permette
létalité du casque des gants ça peut empêcher les
fermetures éclair de se refermer ça use très très
vite tous les matériaux ça irrite beaucoup les
astronautes auront tous et schmidt en particulier
un espèce de rhume des foins en fait c'est une
allergie parce que c'est quelque chose d'abrasifs
et de très très agressif donc ils se roulent dans
la poussière mais on leur dit de faire attention
je me to lie voulait aussi se poser sur la face
cachée mais il aurait fallu envoyer un satellite
derrière pour les relais ce que la nasa n'a pas
voulu faire puisque ont coupé les crédits à ce
moment là est ce que la chine vient de faire et
a envoyé récemment une sonde se posait alors y'a
pas d'être humain à bord mais une somme de se
poser sur la face cachée voilà toujours la même
photo là à quatre kilomètres du lem qui est posé
au milieu des montagnes cette mission-là aura
vu les astronautes s'éloigner à plus de 7 km du
lem à un endroit où il ne voyait pas du tout et
qu'on est vraiment mardi voilà la fameuse vallée
d'anjou parler sont sur le flanc d'une colline
toujours avec un rocher qui a été éjecté qui a
roulé là comme ça le lait mais quelque part par
là ou à l'autre bout lors de la deuxième sortie
sont allés sur cette montagne la première ils
sont aidés par là et voilà le fait c'est le
symbole c'est ce que j'ai choisi comme image
pour la couverture de mon livre parce que c'est
harrison schmitt qui est un géologue qui courent
gay comme le rhône dans un champ de pierres est
très content très heureux il a pas trouvé tout
ce qu'ils voulaient mais mais il a quand même
découvert beaucoup de choses en particulier l'a
permis c'est ces prélèvements ont permis d'établir
la théorie actuelle de formation de la lune qui
est celle de l'impact géant avec une protoplanète
contre la proto terre ce qui est marrant c'est que
je me dis lui croit pas à cette théorie il en
apporter la preuve enfin la preuve en tout cas
si jamais définitive mais mais aujourd'hui c'est
très solide comme théorie et apollo 17 se termine
comme ça avec avec un lancement en direct depuis
la lune filmé depuis dans la lah la jeep la caméra
est toujours en autonome avec les batteries de
la jeep et et à distance il ya aide fender qui
était la personne qui pilotait la caméra avec
un temps de latence quand même d'une seconde et
demie il a essayé de suivre le vaisseau spatial
en incrustation vous avez évidemment les images
et de la remontée depuis le module lunaire qui
repartent vers la terre et donc c'est pas mal
à remonter enfin lorsque harrison schmitt aura
rejoint aaron events un orbite autour de la lune
qu'ils auront prises un message de la présidence
des états unis qui leur sera lui c'est pas nixon
qui téléphonent cette fois c'est moins c'est
moins prestigieux donc on le fait lire à un
administrateur de la nasa et on sous-entend que
peut-être d'ici la fin de ce siècle en 1972 on ne
retournera pas sur la lune et ça ça mes racines
je suis dans une colère noire et il pensait que
ça allait l'exploration allait se poursuivre en
fait il comprend que tout va s'arrêter et pour
longtemps voilà tous ces récits je les ai détaillé
dans ce livre qui fait 500 pages j'ai essayé de
coller au plus près la vie des astronautes sur
la lune j'ai évité tout ce qui était le voyage
a bien sûr je le donne comme élément de contexte
mais c'est vraiment anecdotique parce que tout ça
a été racontée par ailleurs la rivalité entre
les russes entre les américains ça je me suis
pas intéressé des très bons livres là dessus mais
par contre j'ai essayé de raconter tout ce qu'il y
avait du même de drôles sur apollo 16 par exemple
c'était une année olympique en 1972 ils ont voulu
faire un peu les lol voulu faire des victimes des
performances d'un gamin qui lance le javelot puis
font du saut en hauteur ça a failli se terminer
mal parce qu'avec une bêtise comme ça il est
retombé sur son sac à dos qui contient toutes les
réserves d'oxygène il a cru qui s'était tué non il
ya des moments qui sont drôles il ya des moments
qui sont traumatique y aller au mans qui sont
du suspense il ya des moments d'engueulade il ya
eu une grève sur la lune lord apollo 15 il était
fâché contre contre les les contrôleurs de vol à
houston qui leur donnait une mauvaise indication
david scott dit on arrête pendant cinq minutes
on regarde la terre on profite du paysage il a
bien raison j'aurais fait pareil et donc tout
ça je me suis attaché à leur raconter parce que
finalement c'est des petites choses qu'on ne sait
pas qui sont noyés dans des tas de considérations
très technique mais qui sont finalement l'
aventure à l'exploration et le côté humain de
l'exploration de la lune c'est le seul exemple
d'exploration d'un autre corps céleste par des
humains et encore pour longtemps certainement
voilà je vous remercie de votre attention
la superbe superbe aventure fort bien racontée
dans cette conférence forme est racontée dans
dans le livre on apprend encore d'autres choses
un livre qui se lit vraiment très facilement qui
est à la portée de tous je voulais juste dire j'ai
toujours une petite pensée mieux chaque fois que
je lis le récit de ces de ses explorations apollo
sur une petite pensée émue pour celui qui va pas
mettre le pied sur la lune le troisième à chaque
fois y en a un qui reste oui c'est vrai que ça va
être terriblement frustrante d'ailleurs je m'étais
dit que je pourrais en faire un livre mais j'ai
encore moins documents que pour les pour ceux
qui sont allés sur la lune parce que il y en a
vraiment très très peur qu'ils ont qui reste en
vie ils ont vécu l'expérience c'est quand même
étonnante c'est à dire que pendant que surtout sur
les dernières missions ou sa durée quand même un
peu et rester de trois jours tout seul tout seul
est vraiment qu'elle était de l'autre côté de la
lune sur la face cachée seuls dans l'univers
c'est à dire qu'aucune communication le seul
bruit qu'ils avaient c'était le fonctionnement de
leur vaisseau alors ils avaient un travail énorme
il avait un programme d'observation de la lune
etc mais ils ont en outre pris quelques moments
je pense que ça va être une expérience assez
étonnante ils sont vraiment coupé du monde
là c'est vraiment le cas de le dire il était
frustré mais par exemple michael collins le
troisième homme de d'apollo 11 qui est resté en
orbite aurait pu prétendre c'est un astronaute
très expérimentés y compris au moment de la poule
aux il aurait pu prétendre commandé une mission
pour se poser sur la lune et ultérieurement après
tout il y en a qui ont déjà fait le voyage plus
de plusieurs fois il ya jean cerneaux et hatim
lowell et il y à john young donc ça ça pouvait
se voir mais il a estimé qu'il est qu'il a été à
bord d'une mission historique et que finalement il
fallait laisser la place aux autres quelque part
donc voilà en même temps ces gens là ont passé
je pensais des moments contemplatifs tout seul
sans brille au dessus de ce paysage incroyable
malheureusement il n'ya que halo wars and apollo
15 qui est toujours vivant il ya michael collins
et je crois bien que c'est tout donc ils sont plus
sont plus très nombreux assis et ken mattingly de
d'apollo 16 une dernière chose si je voulais vous
demander à vendre avant de vous donner la parole
est ce que est ce que ces missions aurait pu avoir
lieu sans le dramatique accident qui s'est produit
sur terre avec apollo 1 oui vous aurez eu lieu
apollo un bon ccc la découverte qui avis est
énorme dans le fonctionnement de la capsule apollo
ça arrive sur terre alors qu' il n'y a même pas de
carburant dans les réservoirs ont fait juste
une répétition générale c'est un incendie on
s'aperçoit que la capsule est mal conçu que l'aube
siffler oxygène pur c'est très dangereux donc même
pas à sortir non il n'en a pas il leur fallait un
quart d'heure est alors comme fait pour ouvrir la
porte alors là il fallait ouvrir immédiatement
et sortir donc il ya tout un tas de choses qui
sont revus ça retarde et même temps ça a donné un
coup de fouet et les gens de la nasa se sont dits
non on ne peut pas abandonner en plus on ya laissé
trois hommes et non des moindres enfin il y avait
et dwight qui était un très bon astronautes et qui
a été le premier américain à sortir dans l'espace
qui aurait peut-être été celui qui aurait marché
sur la lune un premier s'il n'était pas mort et
avec 2 grissom qui avait été le deuxième américain
dans l'espace donc ce tribut qu'ils ont payé était
lourd et ça les a un peu aiguillonnés pour faire
mieux et peut-être que ça a évité d'autres drames
dans l'espace aussi ce truc là était pas arrivé
à ce moment là malheureusement voilà on apprend
toujours à ses dépens alors est-ce que vous avez
besoin de de précision oui monsieur vous apporte
le micro donc déjà bonjour et merci pour votre
conférence j'avais une question en fait c'est
pourquoi d'après vous il change à chaque mission
leurs l'équipage a est-ce que c'est papin est ce
que cela leur était pas bénéfique de garder le
même équipage et justement les les formes et de
les améliorer à chaque mission en fait il fallait
beaucoup d'astronautes disponible pour l'ensemble
du programme il fallait qu'ils aient on ne pouvait
pas compter sur par exemple trois hommes qui
allaient faire cette émission puis repartir trois
mois plus tard chaque mission demandée aussi une
longue préparation chaque équipage se préparé
longuement pour sa mission en particulier alors
il y avait une sorte de rotation qui existe et
c'est à dire que quand un équipage partent et
il y avait ce qu'on appelait un équipage de
secours encore il y en a un qui tombe malade
c'est arrivé pour fins était suspecté pour apollo
13 il ya un membre d'équipage qui a été changé
donc ken mattingly qui étaient à bord d'apollo 13
étaient suspectés d'avoir la rougeole et comme on
voulait pas qu'ils tombent malades une fois un
chemin on l'a retiré de l'équipage et on a mis
sa doublure qui était jack swagger ce qui est
parti à sa place donc il y avait une sorte de
rotation comme ça où il y avait l'équipage de
réserve qui allait comme qu'ils allaient faire
effectivement un vol trois missions plus loin
parce que ils devaient apprendre à la fois la
mission le doublon de la mission dont il était
de secours et en même temps se préparer pour
une mission suivante en fait il faut savoir
que chaque émission est très spécifique avec
des plans de vol spécifique avec des procédures
spécifiques avec une science spécifiques et donc
on peut pas à demander à un gars qui revient
d'une mission de rembarquer trois mois après
bien sûr il aurait pu le faire et ça aurait pu
arriver notamment sur apollo 17 parce que là
comme les crédits étaient coupées il n'y avait
plus d'astronautes dans la boucle d'astronautes
ou nouveaux qui n'avaient pas volé et donc on
avait pris l'équipage d'apollo c'est joli mais
voilà vous ferez vous ferez l'équipage de
doubler ce qui fait que si par exemple jean
cerneaux harrison schmitt était tombée malade
charlie duke ou john young qui était parti sur
la lune 1 avril 72 ce serait à nouveau retrouvés
sur la lune un dessin présenté 12 mai c'est le
seul cas particulier en fait chaque émission doit
être préparée très en retrait de l'ontario en
amont il faut beaucoup de gens ça prend énormément
d'heures une autre question oui on vient vers vous
ici merci thomas je crois qu'il y avait deux
personnes non qui demandait que l'un à côté
de l'autre non allez-y andré quel ton appris de
la géologie de la lune avec toute la récolte de
pierre de poussières et autres éléments géologique
alors il ya des livres entiers là dessus donc je
vais essayer d'être bref quand même la lune les
échantillons la première information qu'ils ont
apporté c'est la datation absolue d'un corps
céleste sur terre il ya des roches anciennes
mais pas tant que ça parce que vous avez peut-être
finie la technique de tectonique des plaques il ya
du volcanisme les roches terrestres qui sont en
surface les très vieilles y en a très peu et des
roches vieilles de plus de 4 milliards d'années
en fait y en a pas il ya quelques inclusion dans
des roches qui étaient mélangés c'est dès tout
petit échantillon on les a découverts ya pas
très longtemps finir peut-être dix ans ou 15
ans jusque là on n'avait rien de de moins de
3 milliards d'années ou quelque chose comme
ça sur la lune on en est arrivé à avoir des
roches de 4 4 milliards d'années et on a une
datation de certains terrains comme ça en plus
une technique avec selon l'endroit où on prend la
roche et le nombre de cratères et qui a autour on
arrive à reconstituer toute la chronologie de
l'ensemble de la lune on peut extrapoler ça à
mars à d'autres éléments du système solaire donc
c'est comme ça qu'on a bâtie si vous voulez la
chronologie de la formation des planètes et de la
terre et après aussi on a appris aussi l'histoire
géologique de la lune savoir que ça a été encore
qui s'est rassemblée qui a fusionné au sens où les
roches ont fondu parce que il y avait la chaleur
comme sur terre bien que ce soit encore beaucoup
moins massive que la terre donc qu'on appelle
différencier avec les éléments lourds qui vont
au centre aisément léger qui flotte qui font
une espèce de mousse fameuse anorthosis danger
par les c en gros c'est la mousse rocheuse qui
restent en surface on sait maintenant qu'il ya
eu des épisodes volcaniques on sait qu'il ya eu
des gros impact et ses épanchements de lave qui
ont été les mers lunaires il ya aussi des mystères
qui restent encore on sait pas pourquoi la face
cachée et la face visible sont si différentes ça
malgré tout ne sais pas encore on sait que leur
épaisseur et par là même la croûte c'est pas trop
pourquoi donc on a établi une bonne chronologie de
l'histoire géologique de la lune et grâce à la
lune une porno chronologie de l'histoire de la
terre et de toutes les planètes voilà en gros un
résumé mais il ya vraiment de 2,2 d ouvrage très
documenté là dessus et je suis pas expert en la
matière en plus oui en vous donne le micro si
tu veux te remercie dans le même sens ce que on a
on est arrivé à adapter les volcans et est ce que
certains pourraient encore être actifs aujourd'hui
sur la lune oui alors sur la lune il ya quelques
c'est pas des volcans au sens où on voit sur
terre l'etna ou le mont fuji ça ça n'existe
pas sur la lune donc il ya un volcanisme qui est
souvent un volcanisme d'épanchement ces espèces
de failles qui font comme fait on peut on a une
vaste étendue il ya quelques d'hommes volcanique
c'est en gros c'est des petites collines avec
un petit trou au milieu assez petit volcan ça
c'est du volcanisme très tardif c'est à dire cd
dernière remontée de lave qui doivent dater de
1 milliard d'années quelque chose comme ça il ya
eu des études récentes qui ont été menées grâce à
une sonde japonaise qui s'appelle kaguya qui à
cartographier la lune et qui a permis de faire
de la spectraux et de voir un peu les compositions
et comme permis justement de trouver qui avait un
petit volcanisme résiduelles mais c'était dû à des
des poches magmatique qui était en train de finir
de ceux de se refroidir et la lune elle a eu le
volcanisme mais qui ressemble pas au volcanisme
terrestre au sens où c'est pas des c'est pas
des volcans comme common conditions terrain et
c'est fini alors à priori oui c'est à dire que
si le seul volcanisme qui peut rester sur la
lune c'est peut-être des poches de gaz encore
emprisonnés qui à la faveur de tremblements
de lune qui peuvent être causés par les marées
puisque la lune induit les marais sur terre on
les voit bien mais la terre ndi encore plus de
marée sur la lune sauf que cela ne me convient
pas d'eau c'est en ça se voit pas c'est une croûte
très rigide qui est déformé @ 1 ça craque un petit
peu c'est et donc il ya des petits séismes comme
ça où il peut y avoir des impacts qui libère des
poches résiduelles comme ça mais c'est pas
un volcanisme actif c'est quelque chose de
vraiment c'est les derniers les dernières poches
qui sont là et qui vont avoir des espèces est
exhalaisons il ya quelques endroits sur la lune
il ya une par exemple une espèce de dépression
qu'on croyait être un cratère qui s'appelle ina
comédie comme comme lina si c'est pas un acronyme
la ccisom ina qui mesure 1 km de diamètre à peu
près qui est très bizarre et où vous avez un sol
qui est totalement chahuté et qui a l'air très
récent géologiquement alors les géologues ce
point souvent pour savoir si oui les récents mais
non il est pas si récent oui c'est l'expression
ils se disputent pour savoir quel est l'âge de
cette formation se serait par exemple intéressant
d'envoyer une zone où des astronautes creusé à cet
endroit et certains évoquent la possibilité que à
des échelles de temps géologiques récentes donc
pas hyacinthe en paille à milan mais peut-être
un peu plus il ya des poches de gaz qui à cet
endroit ressortent et viennent chahuté la surface
et lui donner cet aspect très jeune mais c'est
tout la lune elle est allée quand même morte oui
encore une question oui décidément il ya que
thomas qui travaillent à elle est au chômage
merci bonsoir pourquoi la nasa a choisi de
former des militaires est principalement des
pilotes d'essai à des métiers scientifiques comme
la géologie et l'astronomie on lui donnerait des
équipages composés d'un pilote pour le poste du
coup de pilotes et de deux scientifiques de métier
aujourd'hui ça se passerait comme vous le dites et
ça se passe comme ça que vous avez des astronautes
qui sont des pilotes il en faut pour conduire la
voiture il ya des spécialistes de mission qui sont
des plus tôt des scientifiques qui ont évidemment
des notions de pilotage donc ça se passe comme ça
aujourd'hui mais il faut se replacer le contexte
l'époque aujourd'hui tout ça est à peu près bien
cadré on sait très bien comment fonctionnent les
vaisseaux spatiaux les connais bien on sait les
effets on sait comment il remédie aux rémédier à
certains problèmes à l'époque on découvre tout on
part de rien et la nasa loewe abord que les gens
capables d'avoir les réflexes de pallier au manque
de lin de cilicie le commandant un problème il
faut que l'autre sens capable de piloter aussi
bien que lui la priorité ce n'est pas de faire de
la science à l'époque c'est de battre les russes
et c'est marrant parce que j'ai interviewés
certains de ses astronautes là et tous m'ont
dit ça je l'aurais dit mais c'était formidable
d'aller sur la lune et explorer un autre monde
le pape a rien de tout ça on était là pour faire
le job pour battre les russes c'est tout ce qui
les intéressait ce moment là c'était des dégâts
à ces jeunes un vigoureux et il était là pour
ses très comment dire très patriote très patriote
c'est américaine il voulait vraiment battre les
russes donc on avait besoin de gars très compétent
pour conduire ces vaisseaux spatiaux et croyez-moi
l'informatique à bord c'était rien du tout donc il
fallait vraiment des gars qui tiennent le manche
qui pilote et c'est pour ça que quand on met
harrison suite dans les pattes de gym sernam
sa première réaction c'est à dire moi j'y vais
pas et d'ex layton le patron des astronautes lui
dit attention il n'y a pas d'autres trains pour
la lune c'est fini après on dit bon j'accepte à
1 et finalement il reconnaît après que harrison
suite qui est passé lui c'est pas un pilote au
départ il est passé par tous les entraînements de
tous les pilotes il a appris à prêt à piloter des
jets et là il a appris tout tout tout le minimum
c'est même plus que ça en fait quand je disais que
c'était un pilote aux moyens annonce un très bon
pilote mais par rapport au pilote d'essai qui sont
la crème de la crème pour eux ils paraissaient un
peu moyen mais serna reconnu après que il aurait
très bien pu faire le plus faire le job aussi de
piloter le module lunaire en cas de pépin voilà
pourquoi à l'époque il fallait vraiment que chaque
membre d'équipage soit vraiment interchangeables
à un autre et soit capable de pallier à tout
manquement des machines parce que c'est ce qu'on
redoutait le plus à juste titre puisqu'on l'a vu
par exemple avec apollo 13 ans on va peut-être
rester là pour ce soir de toute façon vous pouvez
aller discuter avec philippe et d'un eros là
au premier étage enfin au rez-de-chaussée même
de des champs libres on va vous remercier à fait
librement dans ce but et cette belle histoire que
vous avez raconté lorsque le plaisir et que vous
racontez vraiment fort bien dans ce livre que je
vous invite à aller ce guide ainsi que les autres
d'ailleurs merci à toute notre équipe je remercie
particulièrement max et franck qui ont bien
travaillé pour parce qu'il ya eu quelques petites
difficultés au moment des essais merci à vous
deux vraiment merci à toute notre équipe et puis
bien sûr cette conférence et d'enregistrer vous
pouvez la revoir à partir de demain sur la chaîne
youtube de l'espace des sciences et n'oubliez pas
toujours les rendez vous que vous donne le bruno
et priscilla et toute leur équipe au planétarium
de l'espace des sciences très bonne soirée à tous
merci de votre attention et à la semaine prochaine